ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WE
DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM.
BUT WE WILL START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR HELL.
WHO HAS TWO BILLS BEFORE US SB
TWO TWENTY TWO AND SB THREE
TWENTY SIX HAVE A PREFERENCE I
WOULD IF WE COULD START WITH SB
THREE TWENTY SIX THE WITNESS IS
STUCK IN SECURITY?
OKAY -- SB THREE TWENTY SIX THEN
BUT OUR OUR ITEM NUMBER FIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND A GOOD MORNING.
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE TEN
OF THE ANALYSIS THANK YOU WHICH
WHICH CLARIFIES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN IMPOSE
REQUIREMENTS GREATER THAN THOSE
IN THE MEASURE.
SB THREE TWENTY SIX BUILDS UPON
LAST YEAR'S SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE
WHICH I AUTHORED TO ADDRESS
BALCONY INSPECTIONS AND REPAIRS
FOR APARTMENT BUILDINGS
FOLLOWING THE DEADLY TWENTY
FIFTEEN BERKELEY BALCONY
COLLAPSE.
THAT KILLED SIX AND INJURED
SEVEN SB THREE TWENTY SIX
REQUIRES THAT EXISTING
CONDOMINIUM BUILDINGS GOVERNED
BY HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS HAVE
INSPECTIONS AT LEAST ONCE EVERY
NINE YEARS ON A SMALL PERCENTAGE
OF THEIR BALCONIES.
STAIR WELLS AND OTHER EXTERIOR
ELEVATED ELEMENTS TO ENSURE THEY
ARE SAFE.
SB THREE TWENTY SIX ALSO
PREVENTS BUILDERS FROM PLACING
LANGUAGE IN AN H. ALWAYS
COVENANTS CONDITIONS AND
RESTRICTIONS ARE CCAR'S.
THAT WOULD LIMIT THE ABILITY OF
THE H. AWAY BOARD OF DIRECTORS
TO SUE THE DEVELOPER IF THERE
ARE CONSTRUCTION DEFECTS THIS IS
NOT A HYPOTHETICAL SITUATION
COLLEAGUES.
A CASE IS CURRENTLY BEING
LITIGATED IN SAN FRANCISCO WHERE
A REACH A ROUTINE WATER LEAK
REVEALED THAT A MAIN WALKWAY ON
THE THIRD FLOOR WAS ABOUT TO
COLLAPSE DUE TO WOULD DRIVE.
WITH THE H. AWAY BOARD ATTEMPTED
TO FILE A CIVIL SUIT AGAINST THE
DEVELOPER.
THEY FOUND REQUIREMENTS IN THEIR
CCAR'S PLACED THERE BY THE
DEVELOPER.
THAT REQUIRED A FULL MEMBER VOTE
BEFORE THEY COULD LEGALLY SEEK
DAMAGES A TOOK THE BOARD MONTHS
TO CONDUCT THE MEMBER VOTE.
AND THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
ON CONSTRUCTION THAT DEFECT
LAWSUIT NEARLY RAN OUT.
THIS MEASURE HAS A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I DO HAVE WITNESSES
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU THANK YOU
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION'S
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
ACTION COMMITTEE.
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL -- LAST YEAR WE OPPOSED SB --
SEVEN TWENTY ONE WE DID NOT FEEL
THAT THE MEASURES -- THE WORDS
WITHIN IT FITS WITH COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS AND THE GOVERNING
STRUCTURE AND HOW WE MANAGE OUR
OUR BUILDINGS ARE INFRASTRUCTURE
MAINTENANCE REPAIRS AND NGUYEN
SENATOR HILL AGREED TO TAKE OUT
THE LANGUAGE OF COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT WE AGREED TO WORK
WITH HIM ON A REASONABLE
APPROACH THAT FIT THE GOVERNANCE.
STRUCTURE OF COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS AND WE'RE HERE
TODAY TO SAY THAT SB THREE
TWENTY SIX ACCOMPLISHES THAT --
AND WE ARE PROUD TO BE A
SUPPORTER AND SPONSOR OF THE
BILL A WE BELIEVE THAT IT
PROVIDES REASONABLE TIME LINES --
THAT WORK WITHIN AN ASSOCIATION
TO PRESERVE STUDY -- AND THAT
THE REPAIR AND MAINTENANCE
SCHEDULES THAT WILL ALLOW FOR
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS AROUND
THE STATE TO BUDGET
APPROPRIATELY.
AND THEN MANAGED THE SITUATIONS
THAT MAY OCCUR WITH AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE SPECIFICALLY
BALCONY INTO AN ELEVATOR
STRUCTURES AND SO WITH THAT WE
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US PLEASE
MORNING GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARK CONTRARY IN IN THE THIRTY
FIVE YEARS THAT I'VE.
PRACTICE LONG CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTED BOTH PLAINTIFFS AND
DEFENDANTS.
IN CONSTRUCTION DEFECT
LITIGATION THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AS A PRACTITIONER I FEEL THIS
LEGISLATION IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR TWO BASIC REASONS.
FIRST THAT PROTECTS HOME BUYERS
FROM DANGEROUS AND LATENT --
HIDDEN CONSTRUCTION DEFECTS IN
ELEVATED STRUCTURES.
IT ALSO PROMOTES COMPLIANCE WITH
THE PRE LITIGATION DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROCEDURES THAT
ALREADY EXIST.
UNDER CIVIL CODE SECTION EIGHT
NINE FIVE ALSO KNOWN AS TITLE.
SEVEN FOR THE RIGHT TO REPAIR
LOFT WE GENERICALLY REFER TO IT
AS SB EIGHT HUNDRED FORMERLY
SENATE BILL.
EIGHT HUNDRED A REGULAR AND
PERIODIC INSPECTIONS OF ELEVATED
STRUCTURES BY PROPERLY LICENSED
AND TRAINED EXPERTS IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY.
BECAUSE THESE CONDITIONS ARE NOT
APPARENT TO HOMEOWNERS.
WHO DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR OR WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING AT?
WE'VE HANDLED MANY CASES OVER
THE YEARS WHERE ELEVATED
DACHSHUND BALCONIES.
HAVE BEEN DANGEROUSLY DEFECTIVE
BUT WE'RE NOT DISCOVERED.
UNTIL THE RIGHT TYPE OF EXPERTS
WERE ONSITE CONDUCTING THE RIGHT
TYPE OF INVESTIGATION.
SO WE APPRECIATE CENTER HILLS
EFFORTS ON THIS IMPORTANT SAFETY
ISSUE AND ENERGY OR SUPPORT FOR
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR NELSON SUPPORTS --
SING NONE AS THEIR OPPOSITION.
BY SINGER BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR FOR AN AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIMES
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE WILL TAKE
THAT UP ONCE WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU THEN I TO OUR ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB TWO TWENTY TWO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
MISTER CHAIR.
UP FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE WORK
ON THIS BILL.
SB TWO TWENTY TWO IS A
REINTRODUCTION OF ITS ME
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN FROM LAST
YEAR.
WHICH SHIP PASSED THIS COMMITTEE
AND FULL LEGISLATURE WITH BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SB TWO TWENTY
TWO WOULD PROTECT VETERANS.
AND MILITARY PERSONNEL FROM
HOUSING DISCRIMINATION AND
ENSURE THAT LANDLORDS CANNOT
DENY HOMELESS VETERANS HOUSING
BASED SOLELY ON THE FACT THAT
THEY RECEIVE A RENTAL ASSISTANCE
VOUCHERS.
US VETERANS IN THOSE CURRENTLY
SERVING IN THE ARMED FORCES ARE
PROTECTED FROM EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION BY THE CALIFORNIA
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT.
HOWEVER THE LAW DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDE VETERANS OR
MILITARY PERSONNEL AMONG THOSE
WHO ARE PROTECTED FROM HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION.
ALMOST EVERY OTHER PROTECTED
CLASS IN THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ACT IS PROTECTED IN BOTH
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION.
SB TWO TWENTY TWO WOULD ADDRESS
THIS GAP BY ADDING VETERANS AND
MILITARY PERSONNEL AS A
PROTECTED CLASS IN STATUTES
RELATING TO HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION.
THE BILL WILL ALSO ENSURE OUR
HEROES ARE NOT DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST IN HOUSING AND ARE NOT
TONIGHT HOUSING BECAUSE OF HOW
THEY PAY THEIR RENT.
LAST YEAR WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA OF THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION TO REMOVE
THEIR OPPOSITION.
THESE ORGANIZATIONS REMAIN
NEUTRAL ON THIS YEAR'S VERSION
OF THE BILL.
OUR VETERANS AND MILITARY
PERSONNEL ALREADY FACE
SIGNIFICANT HOUSING CHALLENGES
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT BEING DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST WHEN TRYING TO FIND A
HOME FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
I DO HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU THANK YOU
FIRST WITH THIS PLACE YEAH --
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GREG HAYES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IT'S A
CONSORTIUM OF SEVEN NON PROFITS
AROUND CALIFORNIA THAT SERVE
VETERANS -- WE WE CONSIDER
GREATEST NEED AROUND THE AREAS
OF HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING AND
MENTAL HEALTH.
AND THIS BILL'S PRETTY CRITICAL
WE HAVE HAD ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE --
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS WE ARE
CASE WORKERS HAVE ENCOUNTERED
THIS WITH VETERANS WE HAVE AS WE
ALL KNOW ONE OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING.
MARKETS RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
FINDING HOUSING.
LANDLORDS ARE TURNING AWAY
VETERANS WITH HAD VAST VOUCHERS
FREQUENTLY AND I JUST TO
UNDERSCORE THE ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
MARCH.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE OUT
WASHINGTON ATTORNEY STATE
WASHINGTON ATTORNEY GENERAL I
DID -- A BIT OF STAYING ON THIS
PARTICULAR CHALLENGING PROBLEM
SAID A EMAIL TO FIFTY RANDOM
LANDLORDS IN WASHINGTON --
ASKING IF THEY WOULD ACCEPT THE
HIDE BASH VOUCHER FOR HOUSING
TEN JUST SENT BLANKET RESPONSES
OF NOW.
HI AND THEY WERE VARYING LEVELS
OF CHALLENGES BEYOND THAT FOR
THE REMAINING FORTY AND THE BUT
URBAN INSTITUTE STUDY.
ALSO LAST YEAR I FOUND THAT IN
LOS ANGELES 76% OF LANDLORDS
WERE TURNING DOWN -- VOUCHERS
FOR HOUSING SO THE WE CONSIDER
THIS A PRETTY ACUTE PROBLEM HI
FOR THOSE WE SERVE AND WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
IN THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMON THREATS.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
WE HAD A VERY ROBUST DISCUSSION
LAST WEEK ON A RELATED ISSUE BUT
TO EXTENDED NOW IS A PROTECTED
CLASS.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR DOING
THIS I THINK HOMELESSNESS AMONG
OUR VETERANS IS A BIG ISSUE.
AND I LIKE THE ANECDOTAL
INFORMATION THAT WAS PROVIDED.
HI IN SAN BERNADINO I WANT TO
SHARE THAT WE HAVE DONE A GREAT
JOB OF PROVIDING HOUSING FOR OUR
VETERANS.
BUT THE DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
OUR VETERANS WITH VOUCHERS IS
CLEAR THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
SPEECH NORRIS.
GOOD MORNING AT SENATOR AS YOU
NOTED THIS IS A RE INTRODUCTION
OF A BILL THAT WAS VETOED LAST
YEAR.
BY GOVERNOR BROWN AB.
BECAUSE HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THE CONCERNS THAT HE REYES WHAT
A MESSAGE THE GOVERNOR WAS
CONCERNED IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY AND I DON'T REMEMBER
WHETHER HE WAS CONCERNED ABOUT
WANT WHICH PART IT WAS -- I
THINK HE WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ISSUE OF OF THE PROTECTED CLASS
THAT WOULD BE CREATED FOR THIS
FOR HOUSING AND I THINK THAT --
AS WE KNOW AND IT'S JUST BEEN
ARTICULATED VETERANS SHOULD BE
PROTECTED IN HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION BECAUSE WE SEE
EVIDENCE OF THAT AND IT SHOULD
JUST A BASIC PHILOSOPHICAL
DISAGREEMENT I THINK WE HAVE
WITH THE GOVERNOR.
RIGHT AND I THINK THEY ARE THE
OTHER CONCERN THAT HE REYES WAS
THAT THIS WAY TO COMPILE.
PROPERTY OWNERS TO PARTICIPATE
IN A PROGRAM THAT ENCOUNTERING
CUMBERSOME SO.
AND IN THE HOW TO PROGRAM THAT
WE SEE IN THE TO PUT IT INTO
CONTEXT.
IN CALIFORNIA THERE ARE A TOTAL
OF EIGHTEEN HUNDRED BASH BATCH.
IN THE ENTIRE STATE WITH SIX SIX
MILLION RENTAL UNITS.
THE IMPACT THAT WOULD HAVE IS
MINIMAL THE BENEFIT IS
EXTRAORDINARY.
AND I THINK THAT WHEN YOU PUT IT
IN CONTEXT AND PERSPECTIVE WE
CAN SEE THAT IT'S A IT'S A MINOR.
PERHAPS INCONVENIENCE AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS RENTAL PROPERTY.
AND WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
GO THROUGH WHATEVER IS NECESSARY
AND AND FROM WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IT'S IT'S SPECIFIC TO WHATEVER
HOUSING AUTHORITY IN THE COUNTY
THAT IN WHICH THE PROPERTIES
LOCATED.
UP AND MANY HAVE MADE IN
STREAMLINED THE PROCESS TO THAT
THEY CAN GET THROUGH IT
EXPEDITIOUSLY AND IT'S NOT A
BURDEN ON THE LANDLORDS THAT
CORRECT.
YES OF COURSE.
I I'M IF I IF I MAY I JUST WANT
TO MENTION TWO THINGS ONE IF YOU
ARE A VETERAN RECEIVING A HIDE
BASH VOUCHER.
YOU ARE ALSO RECEIVING OTHER
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES SO IF YOU'RE
A TENANT TO ME IT'S AN ENVIABLE
SITUATION BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF SERVICES IN ORDER TO
MAKE THEIR LIVES COMPLETE.
AND 25% OF ALL VETERANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
PRESIDING CALIFORNIA IN THE
UNITED STATES -- SO PRETTY
INTENSE PROBLEM HERE.
AND WITH THE SMALL NUMBER OF
ABOUT VOUCHERS THAT WE HAVE.
YEAH NO I WOULD CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH YOU VETERANS HOMELESSNESS
IS.
YEAH I THINK IT'S SHAMEFUL THAT
FOR FOLKS THAT HAVE SERVED OUR
COUNTRY.
EN SACRIFICING MUCH THAT THEY
WOULD BE WITHOUT.
A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD NURSE YES
MA'AM THAT WE CAN CAN DO -- SO
AGREE WITH YOU THAT IT IS AN
ACUTE AN IMPORTANT.
SHE PRESSED ITSELF.
THANK.
RIGHT CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE IT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RELIABILITY
APPROPRIATE TIME MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE DISCUSSION
AND AND CONVERSATION CREATING
HELP THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR.
ALRIGHT SENATOR JACKSON OUR ITEM
TO SB
.
ONE SEVENTY ONE THE SYSTEM RAMOS
FAVOR [inaudible]
PAY DATA.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING.
THIS IS A SB.
ONE THOSE ITEMS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
WHICH MAY CLARIFYING AND
TECHNICAL CHANGES REGARDING WHAT
IS INDIVIDUALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION.
AND SPECIFIED THAT A REPORT OF
AGGREGATE DATA BY IDEA PH MAY BE
PUBLISHED ON AN ANNUAL BASIS I
WOULD LOVE TO SEE IT AS A SHELL.
BUT I FEAR THE COST IS GOING TO
UNDERMINE THE INTENT OF THE BILL
SO.
MAY.
SEEM TO BE THAT POINT -- THAT
WOULD JOB -- BE AVAILABLE AND
AND WORTH -- WORKABLE FOR
EVERYONE.
THIS IS A BILL TO FIGHT PAY
DISCRIMINATION WITH DATA WITH
INFORMATION BECAUSE WHEN IT
COMES TO PAY EQUITY FOR WOMEN
AND MINORITIES.
YOU CAN'T FIX WHAT YOU DON'T
KNOW.
AND WE CAN TALK ANECDOTALLY WE
CAN MAKE ASSUMPTIONS BASED UPON
OUR OWN LIFE EXPERIENCE BUT
NOTHING SUBSTITUTES FOR GOOD
HARD DATA.
AND THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THAT
EMPLOYERS WITH A HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES ARE MORE -- WILL BE
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT A DAY -- PAY
DATA REPORT ANNUALLY TO
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING OUTLINING THE
COMPENSATION IN HOURS WORKED OF
EMPLOYEES BY GENDER.
RACE ETHNICITY AND JOB CATEGORY
THE GOAL IS TWO FOLD.
FIRST TO ENCOURAGE EMPLOYERS TO
ANALYZE THEIR OWN PAY PRACTICES
AND ALLOW FOR SELF CORRECTION.
I DO NOT THINK OR BELIEVE THAT
MOST EMPLOYERS INTENTIONALLY
DISCRIMINATE I THINK THEY DO SO
THROUGH EITHER IMPLICIT BIAS OR
UNCONSCIOUS DECISION MAKING.
AND I THINK THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT A MIRROR IN
FRONT OF THEIR THESE COMPANIES
SO THAT THEY CAN SELF EVALUATE
AND REALIZE THAT IN MANY
INSTANCES.
THEY ARE INDEED DISCRIMINATING
NOT NECESSARILY INTENTIONALLY SO
THIS IS SORT OF A SOFT TOUCH TO
ALLOW FOR ITSELF CORRECTION.
THE SECOND ASPECT TO THIS.
BILLS GOAL IS TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING TO GATHER IMPORTANT DATA
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO SEE PATTERNS
OF WAGE DISPARITIES.
IN IF THEY NOTICE DEVIATIONS
WORE OUT LIARS TO INVESTIGATE
FURTHER SO PERHAPS THIS
DISCRIMINATION IS INTENTIONAL OR
THAT NOTHING IS BEING DONE TO
AMELIORATE IT TO TO CORRECT IT
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHEN YOU ADD
WOMEN AND PEOPLE.
OF COLOR AND ALL THE COMMUNITIES
THAT MAKE UP CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES DO BETTER.
AND TO THIS WILL IT THIS
INFORMATION WILL BE AVAILABLE
ALSO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT IF THEY
REQUESTED.
THIS BILL IS CLOSELY MODELED
AFTER EFFORTS THAT WERE DONE AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
RECOGNIZING THAT ON EQUAL PAY IS
FREQUENTLY HIDDEN FROM VIEW. TO
BOTH EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYEES THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED A
PROPOSED REVISION TO THE
DEMOGRAPHIC REPORT THAT LARGE
EMPLOYERS HAVE BEEN SUBMITTING
FOR MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS.
THIS IS THE EMAIL ONE THE
EMPLOYER INFORMATION REPORT.
THAT HAS BEEN.
A REQUIRED ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL
FOR AGAIN -- HALF A CENTURY THE
BILL THAT THIS BILL THEN WILL IT
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE THE
REPORTING A PAY DATA.
BY RACE GENDER BEGINNING IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUY PIGGY
BACKING ON AN EXISTING LONG
STANDING DATA COLLECTION REPORT
THE IDEA WAS THAT THIS DATA
COULD BE COLLECTED WITH MINIMAL
DISRUPTION TO EMPLOYERS.
BUT IN AUGUST TWENTY SEVENTEEN
PREDICTABLY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION SAID EQUAL PAY
EFFORTS BACK BY PUTTING A WHOLE
TO THIS NEW RULE.
THE NATIONAL WOMEN'S LAW CENTER
SUIT.
ARGUING THAT THE OFFICE OF
MANAGEMENT BUDGET LACK GOOD CARS
TO STAY THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
PAY DATA COLLECTION.
IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR A FEDERAL
JUDGE ORDERED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO MOVE FORWARD.
WITH COLLECTING THIS IMPORTANT
DATA CITING THE EXTENSIVE
PREPARATION STE SAUDI AN INPUT
THAT WENT INTO THE CREATION OF
THIS DATA REVISION.
AND DECLARING THE OFFICE OF
MANAGEMENT AND BUDGET'S DECISION
TO HALT THE PROGRAM TO BE
ARBITRARY AND CAPRICIOUS.
IT'S POSSIBLE THIS DECISION
COULD BE APPEALED AND THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT REGARDLESS OF WHAT
HAPPENS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
THIS DATA WILL BE COLLECTED HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY CREATED A VERY VIABLE
TEMPLATE HOPEFULLY WILL CONTINUE
THEIR BUT REGARDLESS WE WANTED
TO CONTINUE HERE.
IT'S OF RIGHT NOW THE COLLECTION
OF THIS PAY DATA REQUESTED UNDER
THIS BILL IS IN FACT UNDER WAY
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
AND THIS MEASURE AGAIN INSURERS
THE DATA WILL BE IN THE HANDS OF
OUR STATE AGENCIES AS WELL.
AN EMPLOYER MAY COMPLY BY THE
WAY WITH THIS BILL BY SIMPLY
SUBMITTING A COPY OF THEIR E. O.
ONE REPORT NOTHING COULD BE
EASIER BUT THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
WAY.
THAT WE ARE GOING TO ACHIEVE
THAT GENDER EQUITY THAT EVEN OUR
FRIENDS.
IN THE BUSINESS WORLD SUPPORTED
WITH THE PASSAGE OF THE FAIR PAY
ACT I IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND IF
WE WANT TO IF WE'RE SERIOUS
ABOUT ACHIEVING THAT GOAL THIS
IS ONE OF THE TOOLS IN THAT TO
BOX.
AND JOB I'D I BELIEVE IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
THAT WE MOVE FORWARD WITH IT AND
ALL DEAL WITH SOME OF THE
POTENTIAL ISSUES NOW THAT.
SEEMS AT THE THE COMMITTEE IS.
COMING.
TO A QUORUM AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AS WE PROCEED WITH
THAT I HAVE A TWO WITNESSES WITH
ME JESSICA STANDARD OF THE EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES.
AND SHANNON SMITH CRAWLEY WITH A
A YOU W. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH PLEASE GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JESSICA CENTER ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
PRACTICAL SPONSOR THIS MEASURE.
I'M GONNA FOCUS MY TESTIMONY
BRIEFLY ON WHY THE BILL WILL
HELP ADDRESS SOME OF THE MAJOR
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE GENDER AND
RACIAL WAGE GAP THAT PERSISTS IN
THIS STATE AND IN THIS COUNTRY.
I ALSO WANTED DOES KNOW THE EOC
REALLY TOOK A A MULTI YEAR
THOROUGH AND COMPREHENSIVE
PROCESS TO IDENTIFY THE BEST WAY
TO COLLECT THIS DATA.
THE MOST EFFECTIVE DATA TO
COLLECT AND LEAST BURDENSOME WAY
TO COLLECTED ON EMPLOYERS SO
THAT WHOLE KIND OF PROCESS THAT
THEY UNDERTOOK IS REALLY WHAT
THIS AND AND AND RESULTED IN
THEIR PAY DATA COLLECTION FORM
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
IS WHAT THIS BILL IS BASED ON
REALLY GOOD INVESTIGATION AND
AND AND ANALYSIS -- AS CENTER
JACKSON MENTIONED THE REAL KEY
IMPORTANCE OF HIS BILL IS THAT
WHILE WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT EQUAL
PAY AS A MATTER OF IT WOMAN A
VERSUS WOMAN BE -- MAN BE
PERFORMING SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
WORK AND WHETHER THEY'RE BEING
PAID EQUALLY FOR THAT
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR WORK
ANOTHER REALLY PERVASIVE PROBLEM
THAT CONTRIBUTES TO THE OVERALL
GENERATIONAL WAGE GAP.
IS OCCUPATIONAL SEGREGATION
WHICH IS A VERY ENTRENCHED
PHENOMENON WHEREBY WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR OFTEN FOCUSED IN
ARE CONCENTRATED IN LOWER PAID
POSITIONS WITHIN A COMPANY OR
EVEN WITHIN INDUSTRIES.
AND AS CENTER JACKSON ALLUDED TO
A LOT OF TIMES THOSE TRENDS ARE
KNOWN BY AN EMPLOYER AND SO THIS
DATA COLLECTION WILL GIVE
EMPLOYERS OPPORTUNITY TO
IDENTIFY TRENDS WITHIN THEIR OWN
COMPANY THAT THEY MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN AWARE OF AND THEN
POTENTIALLY.
CHANGE THEIR PRACTICES REGARDING
HIRING PROMOTION -- AND PAY
PRACTICES TO BETTER TO BETTER
REPRESENT PEOPLE AT ALL LEVELS
OF WAGES A COULD POTENTIALLY
ALSO IDENTIFY PAY DISPARITIES
ARE UNLAWFUL PROMPTING THEM TO
CLOSE THOSE GAPS -- I WANT ALSO
NOTE THAT BIG BUSINESSES
THEMSELVES OF RECOGNIZE THE
UTILITY OF THIS KIND OF PAY DATA
ANALYSIS WITHIN THEIR COMPANIES
MANY BUSINESSES A PUBLICLY DONE
THAT SALES FORCE GAP STARBUCKS
ARE A FEW.
WHO FOUND THAT THESE PAY A DATE
AUDITS DO REVEAL DISPARITIES AND
ONE FOUND TO BE UNJUSTIFIED THEY
THEN CAN RECTIFY THEIR PAY
SYSTEMS TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE PAID FAIRLY AND FAIRLY
DISTRIBUTED WITHIN THE PAY
SCALES OF THEIR COMPANY --
FINALLY ALL KNOW THAT THEIR TEEN
COMPANIES AND NOW UP TO TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTEEN IN APRIL NOW
TWENTY SEVEN TOOK THE FAIR PAY
PLEDGING CALIFORNIA PLEDGING TO
DO THIS TYPE OF AUDIT.
SO WE SEE THAT BUSINESSES
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE AND
UTILITY OF THIS KIND OF PAID IT
AUDIT WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAPPENS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA DO TAKE THE STEPS. TO
BETTER CLOSE THE GENDER AND
RACIAL WAGE GAP AND AS SENATOR
JACKSON NOTED IF THE FIT FIT
FEDERAL RULE REMAINS IN PLACE
BUSINESSES WILL BE ABLE TO
COMPLY WITH THIS LAW -- BY
SUBMITTING THAT DATA THAT
THEY'VE ALREADY SUBMITTED THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
I WITH THAT WOULD REQUEST RIVAL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA PAUSE
TESTIMONY ENDS TECH PRO PLEASE
STONE HERE GALLAGHER CHAO.
CHIU GONZALEZ.
HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY.
IN CHINA.
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
NORRIS [inaudible]
REYES.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
NEXT WITNESS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US PLEASE
HI THIS IS SHANNON SMITH
CURRENTLY REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
ALL TAKE THE HINT ON THE MOTIONS --
JUST ONE OF THERE'S SOME REAL
CRITICAL DATA.
WE DID A LOT OF WORK SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE STATE SOME
REALLY GREAT BILLS.
BUT THERE'S A LAG IN IN THAT --
THOSE CHANGES SHOWING UP IN LAW.
AND SHOWING IT BUT THEN
STATISTICS AND NOW.
WE HAVE ARE WAITING.
IF WE KEEP WITH THE STATUS QUO
WITHOUT ANY NEW INFORMATION.
WE WILL CLOSE THE GENDER WAGE
GAP WAGE GAP IN A HUNDRED AND
ONE YEARS.
WE DON'T THINK THAT'S ACCEPTABLE --
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT.
IS SENATOR JACKSON'S AND
PROBABLY MOST EMPLOYERS DON'T
WAKE UP IN THE MORNING.
AND SAY THEY'RE GOING TO OVERTLY
DISCRIMINATE ONLY THE DATA SHOW
ABOUT 6212% OF THE UP PAYING
DISPARITY IS JUDY OUT RIGHT --
BIAS OR DISCRIMINATION THE REST
OF IT IS JUST DOING BUSINESS AS
USUAL.
NOT LOOKING AT IT -- AGAIN THE
THE FENCE WENT THROUGH AN
EXHAUSTIVE PROCESS TO WEIGH THE
BENEFIT IN THE BURDEN IT'S GOING
TO BE AN ADDITIONAL OF FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN DOLLARS.
LAWYER TO COLLECT THIS DATA.
IS COLLECTED AT THE TIME OF
EMPLOYMENT IN ITS MARRIED WITH
THE W. TWO DATA.
OF THE GOVERNMENT.
DOES THIS OF WITH -- COLLECTING
DATA THROUGH THE IO FOR FORM.
SO ALSO.
JUST TO CONSIDER THE CUTE THE
CUMULATIVE IMPACT.
OF THIS ON WOMEN'S.
THE ABILITY TO CARE FOR
THEMSELVES CARE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES TO HAVE RETIREMENT
INCOME.
OF THIS.
ESSENTIALLY IMPACTS SOCIAL.
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS -- WOMEN'S
ABILITY TO RETIRE -- SO.
THERE'S NO EXCUSE.
T. GOING SO WE NEED THESE KIND
OF TOOLS AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE CHEN FLOOR ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
SCAN MINE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RENEE BAYARDO SO YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SORRY.
YOUR BUT I GOOD MORNING MR WHERE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JENNIFER BROWN BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
PROPOSAL.
THERE IS NO QUESTION OR DEBATE
THAT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF FAIR
PAY FOR WOMEN WE SUPPORTED THE
THAT LANDMARK LEGISLATION THAT
SENATOR JACKSON -- DO SEVERAL
YEARS AGO WHICH WAS
UNPRECEDENTED I THINK FOR THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY TO COME OUT
AND SUPPORT SUCH -- A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I ALSO PERSONALLY I
PARTICIPATED IN THE TASK FORCE
TO IMPLEMENT THAT LEGISLATION
FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS -- THE
TASK FORCE THAT WAS CREATED AS A
PART OF THE COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE EMPLOYER
COMMUNITY AND THE EMPLOYEE
COMMUNITY BOTH UNDERSTOOD THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OBLIGATIONS AND
BENEFITS UNDER THE FAIR PAY ACT.
AND OUR CONCERN OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN WITH THIS PROPOSAL ON
THE COLLECTION OF DATA IS THAT
IT'S INCONSISTENT WITH WHAT IS
BEING TOLD TO EMPLOYERS WITH
REGARDS TO THE FAIR PAY ACT THE
FAIR PAY ACT THAT FUNDAMENTAL.
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE FAIR PAY
ACT WAS THAT YOU SHOULD NOT
COMPARE TO PEOPLE BASED UPON JOB
TITLES OR THEIR THEIR POSITION
THAT IT SHOULD BE COMPARATIVE
BASED UPON THE ACTUAL DUTIES
THAT THEY ARE PERFORMING.
AND THIS DATA COLLECTION
REQUIRES AN EMPLOYER TO COLLECT
DATA AND REFER A REPORT DATA
BASED UPON JOB TITLES ALONE.
AND SO TO SUGGEST THAT THIS IS
GOING TO SOMEHOW ILLUSTRATE A
DISPARITY IN PAY UNDER OUR FAIR
PAY ACT IS INCONSISTENT WITH
WHAT THE COMMISSION HAS PUT OUT
OR SKEWS ME THE TASK FORCE IS
PUT OUT.
WITH REGARDS -- TO IMPLEMENTING
THE FAIR PAY ACT AND IT'S
INCONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE LAW
ACTUALLY REQUIRES FOR EMPLOYERS
WITH REGARDS TO THE FERRET PACK
TO COMPARE SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
JOB POSITIONS ACCORDING TO
DUTIES NOT ACCORDING TO TITLE --
WERE ALSO CONCERNED WITH REGARDS --
TO THE W. TO INFORMATION THAT'S
COLLECTED THAT INFORMATION IS.
IMPACTED BY PERSONAL DECISIONS
OF THE EMPLOYEES THEMSELVES THE
FAIR PACKED SAYS THAT IT'S THE
RATE OF PAY THAT THE EMPLOYER
PROVIDES THAT NEEDS TO BE THE
DETERMINING FACTOR.
W. TO EARNINGS CAN BE IMPACTED
BY THE DIRECTIONS EXEMPTIONS
PERSONAL CHOICES THAT AN
EMPLOYEE MAKES AND AGAINST YOUR
REPORTING THAT INFORMATION AND
BASED UPON.
JOB TITLES AND W. TO EARNINGS
THERE MAY BE FALSE POSITIVES OF
WAGE DISPARITY WERE WHAT NINE
ACTUALLY EXISTS -- OUR OTHER
CONCERN IS THAT IS APPLICABLE TO
ANY EMPLOYER WITH A HUNDRED MORE
EMPLOYEES BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S A HUNDRED
MORE EMPLOYEES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WHETHER OR NOT THIS REPORT
IS ONLY LIMITED TO THOSE
EMPLOYEES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW CALIFORNIA'S
UNIQUE AND THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY DOES NOT NECESSARILY
HAVE THE SAME EQUAL PAY LAWS
THAT CALIFORNIA DOES AND SO FOR
COLLECTING DATA.
ON EMPLOYEES AND OTHER STATES
WHAT RELEVANCY IS THAT FOR
PURPOSES OF DETERMINING WHETHER
OR NOT I EMPLOYERSARE COMPLYING
WITH CALIFORNIA'S EQUAL PAY LAW.
ADDITIONALLY -- I'VE HEARD ALSO
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
YOU CAN JUST SUBMIT THE EO ONE
FORM AND BE COMPLIANT WITH THE
SLOT THAT'S NOT WHAT THE BILL
SAYS IT SAYS IF IT'S
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
INFORMATION THEN YOU CAN COLLECT
OUR ESTIMATE THE EO ONE FORM BE
COMPLIANCE BUT OUR CONCERN IS.
THE PERSPECTIVE OF WHETHER OR
NOT THE EO ONE FORM AND THIS
REPORT ARE SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
MAY I BE IN THE AGENCIES
PERSPECTIVE NOT THE SAME AND SO
YOU ARE CREATING AN ADDITIONAL
BURDEN ON EMPLOYERS TO SUBMIT A
SEPARATE DATA REPORT.
IF IT IS THE INTENT OF THE
AUTHOR WHICH WE HOPE IT IS THAT
YOU CAN JUST SUBMIT THE EO ONE
FOREMAN BEING COMPLIANCE AND WE
WOULD HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATION
IS AMENDED TO REFLECT THAT.
AND FINALLY I'LL SAY THERE'S A
LOT OF COMPANIES WHO HAVE DONE
AMAZING THINGS SINCE THE FAIR
PAY ACT WAS IMPLEMENTED THEY
HAVE DONE INTERNAL AUDITS THEY
HAVE DONE INTERNAL HE REPORTS TO
MAKE SURE.
THAT THEY ARE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
FAIR PAY ACT BUT AGAIN THOSE
AUDITS ARE BASED UPON
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR DUTIES
THEY'RE NOT BASED UPON JOB
TITLES AND SO THOSE AUDITS ARE
NOT THE SAME AS WHAT'S BEEN
REQUESTED AS A PART OF THIS DATA
REPORT.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE BURDEN THIS
IS A PLACE IN ON THE EMPLOYER
WHETHER OR NOT THE INFORMATION
COLLECTED IN BEING SUBMITTED HIS
EVEN RELEVANT FOR PURPOSES OF
CALIFORNIA'S FAIR PAY ACT.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED.
MR MILLER JR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF THE OF
CALIFORNIA AMBULANCE ASSOCIATION
COUNTY I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WITH
SENATOR JACKSON AND OTHERS ON
THE ON SB THREE FIFTY EIGHT AND
THE SUBSTANTIAL AMENDMENTS WE
MADE TO LABOR CODE SECTION LEVIN
NINETY SEVEN POINT.
FIVE AND I WOULD JUST HAD A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS TO THOSE
ALREADY ENUMERATED BY MYSTERY OR
THE FIRST IS THAT I'M NOT SURE
THAT THE EO ONE FORM IS THE
PANACEA OF THAT.
THE AUTHOR AND PROPONENTS VIEW
IT AS A SPECIALLY IN THE
AGGREGATE DATA WE WOULD IN FACT
EXPECT.
A FAIR AMOUNT OF PAY DISPARITY
IF YOU WOULD.
A CLEARLY WHAT IS IMPORTANT
UNDER THE LAW AS WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S A VIOLATION OF THE LAW.
IS SB THREE FIFTY EIGHT
ENUMERATED THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
BONTA FIGHT FACTORS.
A AS TO WHY PAY DISPARITY IS IN
FACT LAWFUL SUCH AS EDUCATION
TRAINING AND EXPERIENCE IN OTHER
WORDS WE WOULD HOPE THAT.
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS BEEN
EMPLOYED BY ABC COMPANY. FOR TEN
YEARS AS PAID SUBSTANTIALLY MORE
THAN THE INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS JUST
RECENTLY HIRED IN THE PAST SIX
MONTHS.
THE SECOND POINT IS.
MANY OF THESE BUSINESSES ARE
ALREADY DOING THIS TYPE OF DATA
NOT JUST THE THE PRE WORK BUT
THIS WOULD BE THE THIRD TIME IN
WHICH COMPANIES WOULD BE
SUBMITTING THIS DATA SO I'M NOT
SURE THAT THIS NOTION OF WHAT WE
DON'T SEE WE DON'T KNOW COMMENT
THAT'S BEEN MADE.
OBVIOUSLY MANY OF THE COMPANIES
PRIOR TO THE ENACTMENT OF SB
THREE FIFTY EIGHT I'M ITS
EFFECTIVE DATE -- ONE ONE TWENTY
SIXTEEN WERE ALREADY DOING --
PAY DATA REPORTING AND ANALYSIS
OF THEIR OWN COMPANIES AND THEIR
PAY PRACTICES THAT'S WHY YOU SAW
MANY OF THE MAJOR PAPERS FROM
THE LA TIMES TO CHRONICLE AND
SAN JOSE MERCURY NEWS.
NOTING MANY FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED
COMPANIES AND SMALLER COMPANIES
A CHANGING THEIR PAY PRACTICES
TO BE IN COMPLIANCE PRIOR TO THE
EFFECTIVE DATE.
OF THREE FIFTY EIGHT THE OTHER
POINT IS I'M A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED ABOUT -- THE ONE
AUTHORS AMENDMENT ENUMERATE ON
PAGE SEVEN AND I HAD JUST SEEN
THIS THIS MORNING IN THE
ANALYSIS.
THAT ANY INDIVIDUALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION
SUBMITTED IS NOT SUBJECT TO A
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST --
WHEN THE THE AMENDMENTS WERE
ORIGINALLY DONE LAST YEAR IN
LAST YEAR'S VERSION OF THIS BILL?
IT WAS TO ALL OF THE DATA BEING
SUBMITTED EITHER IN THE EO ONE
FORM OR WHAT THE BILL NOW SAYS
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR -- WE ALSO
HAVE OFFERED TO THE AUTHOR TO
IMPORTANT AMENDMENTS ONE THE
ITEM THAT WAS A NUMERATOR BY
MYSTERY ARE ON THE SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR WE WOULD.
RATHER STRIKE THAT LANGUAGE AND
SIMPLY SAY THE SUBMISSION OF THE
EO ONE FORM -- INSURERS
COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATUTE AND
THEN THE SECOND ITEM IS LIKE THE
FEDERAL LAW.
THAT -- ANY DISCLOSURE OF THIS
INFORMATION WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THE SAME MISDEMEANOR THOUSAND
DOLLAR PENALTY AS FEDERAL LAW
ENUMERATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
IF YOU COME FOR GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
LOCAL RICE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSED AND
ALSO HAVE TALKED TO THE AUTHOR
ABOUT THE SUBSTANTIAL SIMILAR.
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL AND WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT REMOVED AS WELL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MATTHEW ALL OF
WESTERN GROWERS ARE SUPPOSED.
GOOD MORNING KATIE AND SOME OF
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WERE OPPOSED AS WELL.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
PRICING NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SINGER SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THAT THE ARGUMENTS
AGAINST THIS BILL ARE APPLES AND
ORANGES.
THIS ISN'T ASKING WHETHER THE
FAIR PAY ACT IS BEING COMPLIED
WITH.
THIS IS LOOKING AT THE THIRTY
THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL ABOUT JOB
SEGREGATION INTO IT DIFFERENT
ISSUE.
THIS IS WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE
FINDING WOMEN AND MINORITIES
CAST INTO THE LOWER PAYING JOB
CATEGORIES.
NOT WHETHER OR NOT INDIVIDUALS
ARE BEING PAID THE SAME FOR THE
SAME OR SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
WORK THIS IS LOOKING AT TRENDS
THIS BILL.
IS LOOKING TO IDENTIFY.
OF FOR PRIMARILY FOR THE BENEFIT
OF AN EMPLOYER WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE CASTING WOMEN AND
MINORITIES IN THEIR LOWEST
PAYING.
JOB.
AREAS AND IF SO THIS BILL SAYS
FRANKLY THAT MAY BE A VIOLATION
OF THE F. B. H. REQUIREMENTS AND
LAW AND NOW IS IT IS.
BUT THE GOAL IS TO GET THESE
COMPANIES TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT
WE HAVE TO START HIRING WOMEN IN
HIGHER LEVEL POSITIONS BECAUSE
WE ARE DISCRIMINATING BASED ON
JOB CATEGORY.
AND THIS IS A SOFT TOUCH I HAVE
RECORDS ACT SOMETHING I WOULD
NEVER.
UP BECAUSE THE GOAL HERE IS TO
LOOK IN THE AGGREGATE.
WE ARE NOT LOOKING
MICROSCOPICALLY COMPARING ONE
SHOP AGAINST ANOTHER WHERE THE
WHOLE SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
ISSUE MIGHT COME IN WE ARE
LOOKING AT JOB CATEGORIES.
AND I I LOW FRUSTRATED BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY DIFFERENT
TIMES I'VE HAD TO SAY THAT THIS
IS NOT ABOUT THE FAIR PAY ACT
AND I WILL TELL YOU MISS PEREIRA
HAS BEEN A ROCK STAR.
ON THE FAIR PAY ACT BUT THAT
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT THE FAIR
PAY ACT THIS IS ABOUT.
THE DISCRIMINATION THE
HISTORICAL DISCRIMINATION WHEN
YOU HAVE TWO PEOPLE WHO ARE
APPLYING FOR A JOB ONE OF THEM
IS TO BE AN ADMINISTRATIVE VADER
SECRETARY IT HAS BEEN
HISTORICALLY FAR MORE LIKELY
THAT THAT'S THE JOB THE WOMAN
WILL GET.
AND FREQUENTLY IMPORT EMPLOYERS
DON'T THINK ABOUT IT THAT IS
TRUST IN IMPLICIT BIAS THAT
EXISTS EVEN IF THAT WOMAN MAY
VERY WELL BE MORE QUALIFIED THAN
THE MAN WHOSE PULL APPLYING FOR
A POSITION.
THAT WILL ALLOW -- FOR GREATER
JOB GROWTH AND HIGHER
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN THAT.
JOB FRAMEWORK SO THIS BILL IS
ABOUT JOB SEGREGATION THIS BILL.
IS SOME -- DESIGNED TO USE THE
E. L. ONE SO LONG AS IT IS IN
PLACE AND I'M TOLD THAT IN FACT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVING
NOTHING BETTER TO DO.
HAS DECIDED TO APPEAL THE
DECISION.
ON THIS BILL ARE SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT FOR SOME REASON.
THE COURTS ULTIMATELY OVERTURN
THIS LOWER COURT'S DECISION.
THIS WILL BE THE LAW HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IT'S GREAT
TO SEE SOME COMPANIES TAKING
THAT STEP FORWARD BUT WE HAVE A
LOT OF BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
WITH OVER A HUNDRED EMPLOYEES.
AND IT'S ABOUT TIME THEY STEPPED
UP BECAUSE EVEN YOU YOUNGSTERS
HERE AREN'T GOING TO BE HERE IN
A HUNDRED AND ONE YEARS IF WE'RE
GOING TO FIGHT HARD FOR QUALITY
THE TIME TO START IS NOW
ACTUALLY THE TIME TO START WAS A
LONG TIME AGO.
BUT THIS IS A BILL THAT'S GOING
TO MOVE US FORWARD AND GOING TO
GET US TO A POSITION.
WHERE WE CAN LOOK IN THE MIRROR
AND FIX THE PROBLEM AND IF
PEOPLE LOOK IN THE MIRROR AND
ARE WILLING TO FIX THE PROBLEM
WE HAVE VARIOUS AGENCIES WHOSE
TASK IT IS? TO ACHIEVE THAT
LEVEL OF EQUALITY IT WILL GIVE
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE HOPEFULLY RESOLVE IT
SO WE DON'T HAVE TO WAIT.
MORE THAN ANOTHER DECADE IF THAT
LONG TO ACHIEVE THAT LEVEL OF A
QUALITY WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER CHAU.
CHIU GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS IRIS.
REYES AYE.
THAT NEEDS TO MORE SOBER BUT THE
LOCAL THANK YOU SENATOR.
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
TEXAS TO SB THREE EIGHTEEN OUR
ITEM NUMBER
.
FOUR THANK YOU.
FOR THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
SIGNATURE ON MEMBERS. FOR THOSE
THAT HAVE BEEN HERE.
BEFORE YOU'VE HEARD ME TALK
ABOUT.
ON BAIL. FOR PROFIT MONEY BAIL
SYSTEM.
IN CALIFORNIA.
ARMED IN CALIFORNIA BONDS FOR
RELEASE OF CUSTODY ARE IN TWO
CASES ONE IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM -- WHERE THE
ARRESTEE SEEKS RELEASE FROM JAIL
IN THE IMMIGRATION CONTEXT WERE
DETAINEE IS SEEKING RELEASE FROM
CUSTODY OF OUR THE IMMIGRATION
AND CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT --
BRANCH OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WHAT'S HAPPENED IS BEEN IN LARGE
MEASURE -- IS THAT THE COST OF A
BAY ALL OF OF THESE BONDS IS
EXCEEDED OUR ANY REASONABLE
NUMBERS AND SO IN THE LAST THE
NUMBER OF YEARS -- IT COMPANIES
INSURANCE COMPANIES BASICALLY
SURETY COMPANIES OF STEPPED UP
BY YOUR GREAT JOB IS NOW SO AND
NOW.
AT THE THE THEY STEPPED UP AND
AND IN ORDER TO TO FINANCES
STUFF THEY TAKE A SMALL DOWN
PAYMENT FROM THE FROM A PARTY OR
FROM THEIR RELATIVES OR WHATEVER.
AND THEY ENGAGE IN JUST
EXTRAORDINARILY EGREGIOUS PAYDAY
LENDING TYPE PRACTICES FROM
SEIZING PEOPLE'S CARS THE OF
CONTRACTS THAT SAY PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE FOURTH AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
YOU CAN GO IF THERE'S THREE OR
FOUR CO SIGNERS YOU CAN GO AND
SEIZE THEIR PROPERTY IN THEIR
CARS NO LIKE.
AND WE HAVE A CULTURE
JURISPRUDENTIAL CULTURE IN
CALIFORNIA INFORMED BY A
PROTECTION OF THE CONSUMER.
THERE'S AN ARGUMENT OF COURSE AS
TO WHETHER THESE CONSUMER ON
PROTECTIONS THAT WE'VE SET FORTH
IN THIS MEASURE APPLY IN THIS IN
THE IMMIGRATION AND BAIL CONTEXT
COMMISSION CRIMINAL BAIL CONTEXT.
AND A LOT OF THESE COMPANIES SAY
THEY DON'T UCLA TO THE BIG STUDY
THAT SHOWED THESE EXTRAORDINARY
PROVISIONS IN CONTRACTS THAT ARE
JUST UNCONSCIONABLE SO WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE CLARIFYING
IN MAKING SURE THAT.
ALL OF THESE RELEVANT --
PROVISIONS OF THE LAW THAT HAVE
TAKEN FIFTY YEARS THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED IN CALIFORNIA DEBT
COLLECTION PRACTICES AND ALL THE
OTHER TYPES OF REMEDIES WE HAVE
AVAILABLE.
NOW APPLY IN THIS CONTEXT TO BE
CLEAR SO THAT -- EVEN IF THE THE
BAIL IS IS IT A BIT SB TEN THAT
HAPPENED LAST YEAR AND BAILED IT
IS REFORM TAKES EFFECT THEY'RE
STILL GOING TO BE.
A TREMENDOUS COLLECTION
SOMETIMES FIVE OR SIX OR TEN
YEARS PEOPLE ARE STILL
COLLECTING MONEY ON THESE
CONTRACTS AND THEY NEED TO IT
HERE TO OUR THE UNDERLYING
ARCHITECTURE OF BASIC CONSUMER
PROTECTION LAW.
IS MEAN OF A RIGHT TO COLLECT
THEIR MONEY BUT JUST LIKE IN THE
DE FAIR DEBT COLLECTION
PRACTICES THEY'VE GOT TO DO IT
FAIRLY BASED UPON THE RULE OF
LAW THAT APPLIES TO ALL OTHER
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WITH THAT
I WILL WHO'S GOT FIRST SENATOR
THERE ARE AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL
YOU'RE TAKING THOSE IS OFTEN
CANNELLA MOMENTS.
GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
SWEETNESS PLEASE YES.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DAN A CO WROTE DARNELL I'M AN
ATTORNEY AT LAWYERS COMMITTEE
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA -- AND PROUD
CO SPONSOR OF SBTHREE EIGHTEEN
AND WE CREATED THE FIRST LEGAL
SERVICES CLINIC AT LAWYERS
COMMITTEE DESIGNED TO ASSIST
PEOPLE WHO ARE.
SUFFERING THE CONSEQUENCES OF
CRASHING BAIL THAT AND HELPING
THEM UNDERSTAND BOTH THEIR
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THESE
CONTRACTS AND THEIR RIGHTS.
THE RIGHT TO BE FREE FROM
ABUSIVE DECEPTIVE AND UNFAIR
TACTICS USED BY COMPANIES WHO
CLEARLY HAVE THE UPPER HAND.
LET'S NOT FORGET PEOPLE ENTER
THESE AGREEMENTS DURING THE MOST
STRESSFUL MOMENTS OF THEIR LIVES
WHEN EITHER THEY THEMSELVES OR
THEIR LOVED ONE IS BEING HELD IN
JAIL.
LET'S ALSO NOT FORGET.
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE IS
REALLY NOT CONTROVERSIAL.
WHY AND WE'RE NOT FOCUSED ON THE
UNDERLYING SURETIES ARRANGEMENTS
WERE FOCUSED ON THE CONSUMER
FACING BAIL BONDS COMPANIES AND
WE'RE SAYING?
THAT WHEN BAY ON IMMIGRATION
BOND PROVIDERS FINANCE THE FEES
THAT THEY CHARGE FOR THEIR
SERVICES TO CONSUMERS.
OFFERING WHAT THE INDUSTRY
REFERS TO AS CREDIT BAIL.
THAT THEY'RE SUBJECT TO LAWS
THAT REGULATE FINANCING AND
EXTENSIONS OF CREDIT.
WHAT BAY ON IMMIGRATION PONDERED
WRITERS COLLECT ON THESE
OUTSTANDING DEBTS?
THEY'RE SUBJECTTO FAIR DEBT
COLLECTION PRACTICES LAWS WHEN
BEILIN IMMIGRATION BOND
PROVIDERS ENTER CREDIT BAIL
ARRANGEMENTS.
BUT PEOPLE WHO THINK THEY HAVE
NEGOTIATED WITH IN SPANISH
CHINESE TAGALOG VIETNAMESE ARE
KOREAN.
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO TRANSLATE
THESE DOCUMENTS AS REQUIRED BY
LAW.
UNVEILED IMMIGRATION PROVIDERS
PROVIDE SERVICES TO CONSUMERS
SUCH AS COURT REMINDERS CRIMINAL
COURT INFORMATION TRANSPORTATION
FROM JAIL AND WHEN THEY HOLD
THEMSELVES OUT TO CONSUMERS AS
BAIL SERVICE PROVIDERS.
THEIR SUBJECT TO LAWS DESIGNED
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS WHO RECEIVE
THESE SERVICES.
SB THREE EIGHTEEN WILL NOT
INVALIDATE THOUSANDS OF
CONTRACTS AS THE OPPOSITION
CLAIMS.
IN FACT THIS CLAIM IS THE
INDUSTRY USING THE EXACT SAME
TACTICS THEY USE IN ATTEMPTING
TO COLLECT DEBTS FROM CONSUMERS
THREATENING TO THROW PEOPLE IN
JAIL REGARDLESS OF THEIR LEGAL
ABILITY TO DO SO.
THE OTHER PRIMARY CLAIM BY THE
OPPOSITION SEEMS TO BE IT BUT
THEY'VE NEVER BEEN REGULATED BY
THESE LAWS BEFORE.
AND TO WHICH THE ONLY
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE IS
IGNORANCE OF THE LAW IS NO
EXCUSE.
AND OUR POSITION THAT AN
EXCEPTION TO THIS PRINCIPLE
SHOULD NOT BE APPLIED TO THE BAY
ON IMMIGRATION BOND INDUSTRIES.
THANK YOU AND I URGE YOU ON
BEHALF OF ALL LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA TO VOTE
I ON SB.
THREE EIGHTEEN TRISH THANK YOU.
THAT'S WITH US PLEASE.
MY NAME IS TRACY BILLBOARD IN --
I AM A MOTHER OF BUT FORMALLY
INCARCERATED.
CHILD MY DAUGHTER UP AT TWENTY
YEARS OLD SHE'S TWENTY THREE NOW
THREE YEARS AGO ON THE SIXTEENTH
OF THIS MONTH -- SHE WAS
INCARCERATED OF FOR ALLEGEDLY
BEING WHAT BEING AN ACCOMPLICE
ALLEGEDLY BEING ACCOMPLISHED FOR
PERSON THAT STOLE THIRTY SEVEN
DOLLARS WORTH THE DISHWASHING
DETERGENT AT A CVS STORE.
AT THAT TIME MY DAUGHTER WAS --
ACCUSED OF THAT AND WHAT WAS SHE
WHAT THAT THE THE CRIME ITSELF.
THE WHEN WE WENT TO COURT --
THEY GAVE HER THEY TOLD HER THAT
SHE'S GOING TO DO TWO TO FIVE
YEARS IN JAIL FOR THAT -- THIRTY
SEVEN DOLLARS WORTH OF
DISHWASHING DETERGENT THAT WAS
STOLEN FROM CVS -- WE ARE
SURVIVORS OF OF THE WHOLE BILL
SYSTEM WHEN MY DAUGHTER.
WAS RESTED AND I COULD NOT GET
HER OUT OF JAIL -- EXCUSE ME I
GET EMOTIONAL JUST THINKING
ABOUT THIS IS BECAUSE I'VE LOOK
AT IT IS MODERN DAY SLAVERY AND
SLAVE MEANT.
AND WHEN MY DAUGHTER WAS TAKEN
FROM ME AND TAKEN.
TO TO TO SANTA RITA JAIL WHICH
IS ONE OF A JAIL WHERE LIKE NO.
NO ONE WANTS TO GO TO AND THIS
IS LIKE A YEAR AFTER.
THE THE THE THE THEY HAD A A A
LAWSUIT AGAINST WHAT WAS GOING
ON WITH THE WOMEN -- HOW THEY
WERE BEING MISTREATED -- WHEN I
HAD I HAD NO OTHER CHOICE OTHER
THAN WALKING ACROSS THE STREET
WHEN THEY REFUSE TO RELEASE MY
CHILD?
I HAD NO OTHER CHOICE BUT
WALKING CROSS STREET AND GOING
TO A BILL BONDS AGENCY TO GET
HER OUT THEY MIGHT MY DAUGHTER'S
BILL WAS A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
SO I HAD TO PAY TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR LAWYER JUST TO EVEN TRY.
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WAS GOING ON
WHERE FAMILY WE'VE NEVER HAD ANY.
ANY KIND OF DEALINGS WITH THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT I'M AN
INDIGENOUS WOMAN WHO IS FREE
I'VE I'VE ALWAYS LOOKED AT
MYSELF YES IN MY CHILD IS BEING
FREE.
AND WHAT I HAD TO GO THROUGH.
A AND IT WAS WAS WAS A GREGIS IN
JUST EVEN THE FACT MY MOTHER WAS
A COSIGNER AND MY MOTHER ELDERLY
WOMAN WHO WAS BEING CALLED IN.
AND HARASSED DO YOU KNOW OF FOR
THE THE MONEY WE HAD A PAID JUST
IN ORDER TO GET HER OUT WE HAD A
PAID TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS TO GET
HER OUT.
AFTER A YEAR OF PAYING TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS A MONTH.
THE BILL THE THE THE THE PAY WAS
STILL THE SAY IT NEVER CHANGED
IT NEVER CHIANG SOUL.
LUCKILY I GET ON THE ELEVATOR
CENTER.
WAS ABLE TO COME IN AND STEP IN
AND HELP ME IN COLOR YOU LOOK A
COLOR CHANGE WAS ABLE TO COME IN
AND HELP ME PAY OFF THE BILL.
BUT I LOST MY BUSINESS.
IT'S THREE YEARS LATER I I YOU
KNOW I'VE I DID EVERYTHING TO
SELL MY BODY AND MY SOUL IN
ORDER FOR THIS DEBT TO BE PAID
OFF.
I'M STILL THREE YEARS LATER.
I'VE LOST ALMOST EVERYTHING WE
LOST OUR CARS -- IS EMBARRASSING
YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
COME FROM OF YOU KNOW IN A IN
YOUR IN A COMMUNITY WHERE NO ONE
YOU KNOW YOU NEVER.
KNOW HAVE ANY INCARCERATION NOT
ALL OF IT JUST BECAUSE I'M A
PERSON OF COLOR DOESN'T MEAN
THAT WE ALL HAVE BEEN IN THE
SYSTEM.
IN SOLD WHEN YOU'RE IN THIS IN A
IN A SITUATION WHERE YOU DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT TO DO EXCEPT FOR
WALK ACROSS THE STREET.
AND GET YOUR CHILD AND JUST TO
FIND OUT THAT I'M ONLY 5% OF THE
NATION IT ACTUALLY BILLS THEIR
CHILDREN OUT OF JAIL OR THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS ONLY 5% OF US DO
THAT.
ONLY 5% MOST PEOPLE LET THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS LADY IN LIFE.
IN JAIL TO BE [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
SUBJECTED TO WHATEVER MY
DAUGHTER WHEN MY DAUGHTER CAME
HOME EVEN AFTER FOUR DAYS IN
JAIL MY DAUGHTER CAME HOME SHE
STONE.
THE STENCH FROM HER.
YOU KNOW HER FINGERNAILS WERE
DIRTY IT IS OVER THIRTY SEVEN
DOLLARS WORTH THE LAUNDRY
DETERGENT MY DAUGHTER'S TWENTY
THREE YEARS ALL RIGHT NOW AND
CAN'T GET A JOB.
BECAUSE SHE STILL HAS A RECORD.
FOR THIRTY SEVEN DOLLARS AND I'M
STILL PAYING.
YOU KNOW FORT SO EVEN THOUGH THE
BILL HAS BEEN PAID OFF.
I'M STILL PAYING.
SO I HAVE LIKE YOU KNOW.
MY LIFE IS IT HAS BEEN DESTROYED
OVER.
ALLEGATION AND SO I JUST FEEL
LIKE -- PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT HOW AGREE JUSTICE SYSTEM
IS AND HOW PREDATORY IT IS UPON
US.
IN THE PEOPLE AND IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT PEOPLE OF COLOR IS REALLY
ABOUT CLASS.
IT'S ABOUT IF YOU JUST DON'T
HAVE MONEY IF YOU KNOW IF WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO SURVIVE IN THIS
WORLD AND AND THEN YOU GET LIKE
THIS MODERN DAY SLAVERY.
THAT THAT MAKES IT SO THAT YOU
CAN'T.
GET OUT OF OUT OF THE RED.
YOU KNOW I I WANT I WANT MY
DAUGHTER TO BE SUCCESSFUL I HAD
TO CHOOSE.
I HAD TO CHOOSE THE BILL PAYING
OVER MY DAUGHTER GOING TO
COLLEGE.
LIKE THAT TO ME IS STUPID.
IT'S JUST IT MAKES NO SENSE MY
DAUGHTER DIDN'T GET TO GO CAUGHT.
BECAUSE I HAD TO PAY.
THIS BILL AND I HAD TO YOU KNOW
WE'RE IN THE SYSTEM AND THEN
EVEN AFTER ALL OF THAT IT'S
STILL ON A RECORD AND IT WAS.
IT WAS IT WAS REDUCED TO A
MISDEMEANOR.
DISTURBING THE PEACE AND STILL
EVEN THOUGH WE HAD TO PAY THIS
THE SYSTEM WAS STILL PAYING.
WE LOST EVERYTHING.
AND SO WHAT I WANT TO DO IS JUST
I WANTED TO COME HERE TO TELL MY
STORY SO PEOPLE KNOW THAT NOT
ALL OF US COME FROM CRIMINAL
BACKGROUNDS AND EVEN IF WE CAN
AND THEN THE EVEN IF YOU DO COME
FROM THAT.
HE'S STILL IT'S IT'S IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT FAIR WE JUST NEED IT
AND LIKE.
JUST BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW THE
LAW LIKE THE CONTRACTS THAT WE
HAD THAT I HAD TO SIGN I HAD NO
IDEA I WAS SIGNING MY LIFE AWAY
I HAD NO IDEA I JUST WANTED TO
GET MY DAUGHTER OUT OF THE
SYSTEM.
THAT I KNOW THAT WAS GOING TO
GET SHE SHE STILL IT DESTROYED
HER FOUR DAYS IN JAIL STILL
DESTROYED HER.
AND MOST PEOPLE LIKE I KNOW MOST
PEOPLE CANNOT AFFORD TO GET
THEIR LOVED ONES OUT OF THAT
SYSTEM.
AND THAT'S IT'S JUST NOT FAIR.
IT'S NOT FAIR.
AND SO I JUST DO NOT URGENT I
VOTE.
YOU KNOW FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE
THERE ARE YOU KNOW LIKE I SAID
IT'S NOT ABOUT.
COLOR IT'S IT'S IT'S NOT ABOUT
RELIGION IS IT'S ABOUT CLASS TOO
YOU KNOW SO WAS THIS IS ABOUT
ALL OF THAT BUT WE ARE ALL
SUFFERING.
WERE ALL SUFFERING FROM THE
SYSTEM THAT.
IS MAKING MONEY OFF OF PEOPLE
WHO CAN ACTUALLY.
PUT MORE INTO THIS THIS COUNTRY
MORE INTO OUR COMMUNITIES MORE
INSOFAR COUNTIES WARRANTS ARE
CITIES WE COULD DO A LOT MORE IF
WE DIDN'T HAVE TO BE.
YOU KNOW.
WE DO IF WE DO HAVE PREDATORS
UPON US [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
THANKS TO CHAIR TED MERMAN FROM
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION -- PROUD CO
SPONSOR THE BILL CLICKS MEMBERS
ARE MORE THAN A DOZEN LEGAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO WORK WITH
THOUSANDS OF LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS FROM AROUND THE STATE
TOO MANY OF WHOM HAVE HAD.
NEGATIVE EXPERIENCES WITH THE
BAIL BONDS AND IMMIGRATION BONDS
INDUSTRY -- SB THREE EIGHTEEN IS
A VERY USEFUL -- CLARIFICATION
OF EXISTING LAW.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE.
THANK YOU.
CAN FLOOR IN BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
STERN MEMBERS KEVIN BIG OF
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT
FOR ELOQUENT.
TESTIMONY GIVEN BY THE AUTHOR IN
THE PRIOR WITNESSES THANK.
THANK.
AND I ORDERS GO WITH CHIRLA AND
WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
TOTAL PADILLA.
I'M A BILL AGENT. FOR THIRTY SIX
YEARS.
WHAT MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW IN A
LOT OF WHAT WAS ADDRESS JUST NOW
HAS TO THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM HAS NOTHING?
AT ALL TO DO WITH WHAT WE DO.
WE GIVE PEOPLE THE ABILITY TO
EXERCISE A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
THAT THEY HAVE.
THAT SHOULD THEY BE THROWN IN
JAIL.
THAT THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO BAIL
THEMSELVES OUT OF JAIL.
WITHOUT ANOTHE GOVERNMENT
AGENCY BEING THE ONE THAT
WATCHES OVER THEM.
SO I HAD TO TOUCH ON THAT FIRST.
SB THREE EIGHTEEN SIX TO SOLELY.
HAVE THE BAIL INDUSTRY.
HOW ARE DOCUMENTS TRANSLATED
INTO FOUR OTHER FOREIGN
LANGUAGES?
THAT'S WHAT IT DOES SO ALL THE
THINGS THAT WERE DRESSED HAVE TO
DO THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND SOME OF THE HYPERBOLE EASE
OF THE SENTENCES THE BAIL
AMOUNTS HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
THIS BILL FOR ME.
SB.
TEN ADDRESSES THAT AND TAKE CARE
OF THAT A REFERENDUM WOULD DEAL
WITH THAT LATER.
SO GETTING BACK ON TRACK THERE'S
OVER SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
LANGUAGES IN THIS IN THIS WORLD
OF OURS.
MANDARIN CHINESE IS THE MOST
POPULAR LANGUAGE.
WHEN I IS A BAIL BONDSMAN?
GO TO TWO AVAILABLE ON NUMBER
ONE I TAKE GREAT OFFENSE TO BE.
INPUT IS A PAYDAY LENDER.
WHEN BAIL IS SET ON SOMEBODY IF
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY?
THE TWO FOR THE BELMONT WE DO
EXTEND CREDIT.
OUR INDUSTRY DOES NOT.
CHARGE INTEREST WE DO NOT.
GO TAKE PEOPLE'S CARS WE DO NOT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO TAKE AWAY
SOMEBODY'S FOURTH AMENDMENT
RIGHT.
DON'T PLEASE DON'T TAKE THAT MAY
WE HELP PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
CUSTODY WE GET THEM OUT OF
CUSTODY.
YES WE EXTEND CREDIT.
WHEN I HEAR THE FOR PROFIT BILL
INDUSTRY IT MAKES ME ILL TO MY
STOMACH?
EVERY BUSINESS IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT I KNOW OF ITS FOR PROFIT
LESS THEY ARE A NON PROFIT.
THAT IS NOT AN UGLY WORD AND
SHOULDN'T BE USED. TO FOR THE
EMOTIONAL ASPECT OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
SO.
BACK TO WHAT WE DO AN EXERCISE
IN PEOPLE GIVE THEM THE RIGHT.
WE'RE INSURANCE AGENTS ISSUING
AN INSURANCE POLICY. TO THESTATE OF CALIFORNIA GUARANTEEING
SOMEBODY'S APPEARANCE IN COURT.
THAT SHOULD NOT BE TABOO.
THAT SHOULD BE ACCEPTED AND
LOVED AND APPRECIATED BY THOSE
THAT A JUDGE WILL NOT ALLOW TO
BE RELEASED FROM JAIL.
AND NOW THE ONLY RIGHT AND ONLY
ABILITY THEY HAVE TO BE RELEASED
FROM JAIL IS TO CALL AVAILABLE.
IF THE BILLS ARE TOO HIGH THEN
WE'LL DEAL WITHOUT ON ANOTHER
AND ANOTHER.
WE TRIED TO DEAL WITH THAT FOR
MANY MANY YEARS AND THIS VERY
LEGISLATURE TO TRY AND GET THE
BILL'S LOWERED OUR INDUSTRY DID.
V. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT MUST
BE KNOWN IS THAT THERE'S PENDING
LITIGATION THERE IS PENDING
LITIGATION GOING ON RIGHT NOW
AND AND SOME OF THE FOLKS THAT
IF YOU'VE JUST HEARD FROM.
ARE INVOLVED IN THAT.
AND THAT IS REALLY. TO HAVE
KNOWING THAT THEY'VE GOT PENDING
LITIGATION AND THEY'RE GOING TO
USE THIS LEGISLATURE TO HELP.
YOU KNOW IN THAT CASE BECAUSE
THIS DIRECTLY AFFECTS THAT CASE
[inaudible]
HE WHEN WE DEAL WITH OUR CLIENTS
BLESSING I'M GONNA DO IS GO IN
THERE AND AND TALK TO SOMEBODY
OR DO BUSINESS WITH SOMEBODY IF
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M
SAYING.
I'M NOT GONNA DO THAT YES THEY
ARE UNDER GREAT PRESSURE YES
SOMEBODY'S IN JAIL AND THEY'RE
SOMEBODY THAT KNOWS THAT THAT'S
ME IS A BAIL AGE.
AND I HAVE THE COMPASSION. TO
GET THESE PEOPLE IN THIS VERY
TRYING.
CONCERNING NEED TO HELP THEM IN
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS GET THAT
PERSON OUT OF JAIL AND I'LL BE
DOING IF YOU THINK I'M GONNA GO.
YOUR BAIT AND SWITCH ON SOMEBODY.
HAVE THEM WAVE THEIR FOURTH
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING ME.
THEY DO UNDERSTAND AS WE BRING
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT DO COME IN
IF THERE IS A NEED FOR FOREIGN
LANGUAGE WE BRING THEM IN. TO
HELP US TRANSLATE AND HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND.
WE ARE THE ONLY LINE OF
INSURANCE.
THERE IF YOU DO NOT MAKE YOUR
PAYMENT TO US.
ON MY CAR INSURANCE LIFE
INSURANCE HEALTH INSURANCE IN
ANY OTHER FORM OF INSURANCE IN
THIS STATE AND COUNTRY WE CANNOT
CANCEL OUR INSURANCE POLICY.
I CANNOT CANCEL THAT INSURANCE
POLICY FOR NON PAYMENT OF
PREMIUM.
HEALTH INSURANCE CAR INSURANCE
LIFE INSURANCE THEY CAN'T WE
CAN'T.
I CAN'T GO ARREST SOMEBODY AND
THROW THEM BACK IN JAIL.
SHOULD THEY MISS A PAYMENT.
I CAN'T DO THAT.
THROWN BACK IN JAIL FAMOUS COURT.
SO THE BOTTOM LINE WITH THIS IS
SB THREE EIGHTEEN AS ABOUT.
OUR DOCUMENTS BEING TRANSLATED
INTO FOREIGN LANGUAGE BECAUSE
THIS COULD MISCONCEPTION OF
PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND WE'RE
FORCING PEOPLE TO SIGN THESE
CONTRACTS THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT ASPECT OF
THIS IS THE RETROACTIVITY OF
SUCH THIS BILL THAT IS IN IT.
IF THIS BILL PASSES.
IT WILL GO RETROACTIVE TO EVERY
SINGLE CONTRACT IN EVERY SINGLE
PERSON I HAVE OUT ON BAIL RIGHT
NOW AS WE SPEAK.
AND THE ENTIRE INDUSTRY.
AS WELL AS THOSE THAT DO --
MONEY THEY DO AND HAVE ENTERED
INTO A LEGAL CONTRACT AT THE
TIME WE ENTERED INTO IT.
I WILL BE FORCED.
AND THIS IS A FACT THIS IS NOT A
HYPERBOLE ALL MY CONTRACTS WILL
BE KNOWN VOID SHOULD THIS PASS.
FROM MY LIABILITY TO GO OUT AND
GET THOSE PEOPLE AND PUT THEM
BACK IN JAIL.
BECAUSE I WILL HAVE A KNOWN VOID
CONTRACT OUR COURT SYSTEMS WILL
BE AN UPSIDE DOWN THAT IS NOT A
HYPERBOLE I WILL HAVE TO THROW
PEOPLE BACK IN JAIL.
THAT SHOULD NOT BE THROWN BACK
IN JAIL BECAUSE I HAVE KNOWN
WHAT CONTRACT [inaudible]
IN CLOSING.
I A I SAY TO YOU THIS -- THIS
BILL IS ABOUT TRANSLATING
DOCUMENTS INTO FOREIGN LANGUAGES.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THAT.
I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO PROBLEM
WITH DOING THAT.
I WOULD MAKE SURE TO DO THAT.
CERTAINLY I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
UP HERE.
WANTS TO HAVE SOMEBODY FROM A
COUNTRY THAT.
MAY NOT HAVE THE LANGUAGE WE
SPEAK YOUR RELATIVELY AND OFTEN.
AND THEY'RE IN JAIL AND NOW I
CAN'T GET AMOUNT BECAUSE I DON'T
HAVE MY DOCUMENTS TRANSLATED IN
ONE OF THE SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
FOREIGN LANGUAGES THAT EXIST IN
THIS COUNTRY.
WE DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
WE DON'T DO THAT.
WE DO HAVE COMPASSION.
THIS FOR PROFIT ASPECT OF WHAT
IS BEING USED TO LOBBY FOR THIS
BILL IS DISCUSSED.
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU THE NEXT WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION.
BOB MARK SEGMENT OF BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALLY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION IN THE
OVEN THE SHIRT INFIDELITY
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA OUR
BIGGEST CONCERN IS THE POTENTIAL
RETROACTIVE APPLICATION OF THIS
LAW.
AT LEAST AS THE WITNESSES STATED
THERE IS LITIGATION ON THIS I DO
BELIEVE THAT REASONABLE WHITES
DO DIFFERENT WHETHER NOT THESE
PROVISIONS HAVE BEEN APPLIED --
PREVIOUSLY WHAT HAPPENS IF THIS
LAGOS DURING CLARIFIES AND THERE
ARE POLICIES OUT THERE THAT ARE
NO LONGER THE FACT THIS HAS BOTH
AN IMPACT ON THE THE BAIL AGENT
THE INDIVIDUAL HAS BEEN BAIL
THAT DOES HAVE A IMPACT ON THE
UNDER LIGHT SHOW CHARITY WHICH
IS WHY WERE POST.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS [inaudible]
LIKE.
TO YEAH ONE QUESTION FOR THE
LAST WEEK.
SO IT IS IT YOUR VIEW THAT IF
THIS WERE TO PASS SAYING THAT
IT'S CLARIFYING EXISTING LAW --
THAT THAT WOULD SORT OF BE
DISPOSITIVE OF THE MATTER AS FAR
AS THE COURTS -- CONCERNED THAT
BECAUSE TODAY'S LEGISLATURE HAS
GIVEN ITS INTERPRETATION OF
EXISTING LAW -- A COURT WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY APPLY THAT SAME
INTERPRETATION WELL I'M NOT AN
ATTORNEY AND I TRY TO PLAY ONE
ON TV BUT I THINK THE COURT
WOULD HAVE A HARD TIME.
OVERCOMING THE LEGISLATIVE FIAT
THAT THIS IS A CLARIFICATION
EXISTING LAW AND THEREFORE IT'S
BEEN IN EFFECT FOR A LONG PERIOD
OF TIME.
BUT THAT THAT BEYOND AS IT WERE
WOULDN'T.
ACTUALLY APPLY IT RETROACTIVELY
IT WOULD SIMPLY EXPRESSED THE
OPINION OF TODAY'S LEGISLATURE
AS TO WHAT.
YESTERDAY LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATURE TO PASS THAT
INTENDED CRACKS THAT WOULD
NECESSARILY BE DISPOSITIVE.
I WOULD AS SOON THAT ANY GOOD
ATTORNEY WHO HAS ISSUES WITH
THESE TYPES OF AGREEMENTS WOULD
TAKE THE LEGISLATIVE A
CLARIFICATION THAT IS EXISTING
LAW.
AND I WOULD BE SURPRISED THAT
AND GO AFTER EXISTING POLICY
SAYING THEY WERE INVALID.
WHICH IS TO SAY TO MAKE SENSE TO
ME.
YEAH THE OTHER ONE THAT'S AYE
AYE BEING RETROACTIVE
RETROACTIVE -- NUMBER IT IS
RETROACTIVE AND I I DO WANT TO
SAY ONE THING AND I INSPIRED ONE
WAS WHAT HE SAID.
WHY ARE THE OTHER LINES OF
INSURANCE AND I HATE TO SAY THIS
WHY THE OTHER LINES OF INSURANCE?
NOT INCLUDED IN THIS WHY IS IT
JUST THE BAIL BOND INDUSTRY WHY
ARE ALL THE LINES OF INSURANCE
WHY ARE ALL CONTRACTS USE ME.
JUST ANSWER QUESTIONS IF THERE'S
A QUESTION THE TASK I DON'T WE
ASK THAT YOU RESPOND TO THE
QUESTIONS OPPOSED TO POSING
ANOTHER QUESTION.
YOUR QUESTION ANSWERED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SORRY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALSO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE -- CENTER WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE I SURE WOULD AND I
GLANCE OF THE QUESTIONS IN THAT
CLOSE [inaudible]
SO.
IN MAY. TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
UCLA.
CONDUCTED A STUDY.
THAT STUDY DESPITE WHAT YOU
HEARD BY ONE BAIL AGENT.
WHO HAS BEEN THE LEADER OF THIS
FIGHT ON HIS SIDE?
EXAMINE FOUR HUNDRED BAIL
CONTRACTS.
NOT ONE NOT [inaudible]
TEN FOUR HUNDRED AND THAT.
STUDY IN FORMS THE BASIS.
OF THIS BILL.
BECAUSE IN GOING THROUGH THOSE.
FOUR HUNDRED OUR CONTRACTS WHAT
WE DID LEARN IN THOSE EXACT
CONTRACTUAL PROVISIONS.
THAT PEOPLE THAT COULD CONSUMERS
ARE ASKED TO WAIT THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
THAT THEY WERE ASKED A TWO I CAN
GO THROUGH IMAGE IS USED
EXTRAORDINARY THING THAT I
REPRESENTED AS SET FORTH IN THIS
STUDY TO THE EXTENT SOMEONE --
IS HERE IT REQUIRES -- PEOPLE
SIGNING THE CONTRACTS TO A
SURRENDER THEIR LOVED ONES TO
JAIL.
IT REQUIRES A DEMIURGE TO BE
FULLY ARE LIABLE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL EXPENSES.
IT HAS HUGE HIDDEN FEES WE HAVE
EXAMPLES OF PEOPLE THAT ARE A
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR TO PREMIUM
RESULTING IN FORTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN COSTS.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE DEBT
COLLECTION PRACTICES LAW YOU
LOOK AT ALL THE LAWS THAT WE'RE
SEEKING TO APPLY ONLY ONE DEALS
WITH LANGUAGE INTERPRETATION THE
REST DEAL WITH THE BROUGHT
BROUGHT HISTORY.
OF PROTECTIONS AND INFORMATION
AND MAKING SURE CONSUMERS
PARTICULARLY AS WAS SO
APPROPRIATELY AND ELOQUENTLY
ARTICULATED HERE THEY'RE IN THE
MOST VULNERABLE OF THEIR
SITUATIONS.
AND WE HAVE A KHN CONCEPT THE
LOCAL THAT HE'S IN CONTRACTS AND
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS WITH
THE MOST IMPORTANT TIME WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE FULLY
INFORMED MAKE WHATEVER DECISIONS.
BUT THEY'RE FULLY INFORMED SO
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING WHERE --
IT'S ANYTHING FURTHER THAN A
STEP TO MAKE TO TRULY SHINE
LIGHT ON THESE HORRIBLE
PRACTICES THAT HAVE DEVELOPED
OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS
AND THE ABUSIVE NATURE.
OF THESE INSTITUTIONS AND WHAT
THEY'VE DONE WE HAVE A HUGE
NUMBER REPORTS WE SEATED HERE
YOUR TESTIMONY NOT JUST ABOUT
THE IMPACT THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM BUT ABOUT THE HARASSING
TELEPHONE CALLS. TO HER MOTHER
AND ALL OF THOSE THOSE ISSUES
SECONDLY.
THE AS THE ANALYSIS SO
APPROPRIATELY POINTS OUT THE
ARGUMENTS MADE BY THE OTHER SIDE
CONSERVING RECTOR ACTIVITIES
SEEM RECURSIVE.
ON THE ONE TAUGHT HIGH AND
THEY'RE ARGUING WILL THIS
DOESN'T APPLY TO US WE'RE NOT
WE'RE SHIRLEY COMPANY IT DOESN'T
APPLY BUT IF IT DOES APPLY YOU
CAN'T APPLY IT RIGHT IN THE IT
IS A COURT CASE WOULD YOU SITE
WHICH WE REALLY APPRECIATE.
THAT BUT BASICALLY ON POINT
DIRECTS THIS ISSUE ABOUT THE
POWER OF FUTURE LEGISLATURE'S TO
CLARIFY THE LAW TO EITHER A
YOU'RE EXTENDING IT GOING
FORWARD OR BE YOUR CLARIFYING IT
BUT IN EITHER INSTANCE.
THIS IS THIS IS A CORNERSTONE OF
WHAT WE SOUGHT TO DO AND WE'VE
HAD IT INDUSTRY THAT HAS TRIED
TO DEFINE ITSELF HONESTLY I DID
UNDERSTAND THE DISTINCTIONS THEY
MADE UNTIL I START GETTING THIS
FIGHT TWO YEARS AGO.
AND THEY WANTED TO SAY WERE
SURELY AND WE'RE TO SHOULD BE
TREATED DIFFERENTLY AND THE LIKE
WHICH RESULTED IN THE UCLA STUDY
AND RESULTED IN THE OUR EXPOSURE
OF THESE.
WHO ORDINARILY?
OPPRESSIVE APPROACH TO THESE
CONTRACTS WERE PEOPLE ORDER
TOUGH SITUATIONS AND THERE'S
HUGE PRESS REPORTS WE COULD
BROUGHT THEM AND SHARE THEM WITH
THIS COMMITTEE LET ALONE ALL THE
THE THE THE THE EXAMPLES THAT
WE'VE SEEN.
OF THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR THIS IS
AN INDUSTRY THAT NEEDS TO TO IT
HERE TO THESE UNDERLYING
PRINCIPLES AS LONG AS THEY
CONTINUE TO EXIST.
AND IN THE MEAN TIME OUR JOB IS
TO PROTECT EVERY LIFE TO PROTECT
LIBERTY OF EVERYONE AND IF THERE
IS SOMETHING ON THE BALLOT IN
THE FUTURES THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
DETERMINE WHAT THE FUTURE IS.
WELL IMPORTANT THAT WE START NOW
AND WE PROTECT PEOPLE EVERY
SINGLE DAY SO WHAT HAPPENED HER
DAUGHTER DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN I
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BETTER.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO INSURANCE.
KALRA PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER CHAU CHIU GONZALEZ.
AND ALSO I HOLDEN KALRA KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MENTION I OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS REYES.
CHRIS I THE TWO THAT THE FEW
MORE VOTES SO WE'LL PUT IT ON
CALL THANK YOU SENATOR THANK.
OKAY WELL AS WE WAIT.
FOR OTHER AUTHORS ALL TAKE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
THERE'S A MOTION IS OUR SECOND.
ALL RIGHT WE DO HAVE A MOTION
SECOND.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHAU CHIU
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS REYES.
RESIDE.
RIGHT I WILL PUT THE CONSENT
AGENDA ON CALL INTO WE GET MORE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ADD ITEM THREE STILL NEEDS A
MOTION THIS IS CENTER HILLS SB.
TWO TWENTY TWO THERE'S A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE.
BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHAU CHIU
GONZALEZ.
IN SALAS AYE HOLDEN KALRA KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS REYES.
RESIDE.
RIGHT IN THE SAME FOR SENATOR
HILLS SB.
THREE TWENTY SIX I'LL TAKE A
MOTION.
THANK YOU MOTION AND A SECOND
THAT.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHAU CHIU
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA KILEY.
EARLY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MENTION I OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS REYES.
PRESS I SO THE BILL ALSO IS ON
CALL.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR SENATORS
WIENER AND MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
SENATE MCGUIRE.
IRAN.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB.
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN WELL GOOD
MORNING GREAT GREAT WILL BE WITH
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AND MISTER
CHAIR IN MEMBERS FOR ALLOW ME TO
BE HERE TODAY I ALSO WANT.
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK
YOU. TO YEAR AMAZING STAFF TEAM
FOR ALL THEIR ASSISTANCE WITH
THIS BILL MISTER CHAIR AND THEN
BEGIN BY SAYING THIS IS A
COMPLICATED IN CANDIDLY AT TIMES
A BIT OF A DIDN'T ISSUE.
BUT I THINK THAT WERE ADVANCING
A SIMPLE SOLUTION THAT'S BEEN
NEGOTIATED IN A VERY GRATEFUL
FOR ALL THE WORK ON ALL SIDES.
SB THREE SEVEN SEVEN IS THE
CLEAN UP BILL.
WHICH IS FROM A PREVIOUS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT PROTECTS
FOSTER YOUTH FROM THE LONG TERM
SIDE EFFECTS.
OF INAPPROPRIATELY PRESCRIBED
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATIONS I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE CHAIR FOR ALL
OF HIS WORK IN THIS AREA -- AND
AGAIN MISTER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE WITH THE BILL.
THE STATE IS GUARDIAN TO
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY THOUSAND
KIDS AND YOUNG ADULTS AND FOSTER
CARE.
AND WE HOLD THE RESPONSIBILITY
TO ENSURE THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION.
THIS BILL EXTENDS A MONITORING
THE ADMINISTRATION OF MIND
NUMBING PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATION
THAT CAN LEAD AND HAS LED TO A
REVERSIBLE IN LIFELONG HEALTH
IMPACTS.
IF NOT PRESCRIBED APPROPRIATELY.
IN AN EFFORT TO BE ABLE TO CRACK
DOWN ON EXCESSIVE AND
UNNECESSARY PSYCHOTROPIC
PRESCRIBING A FOSTER YOUTH.
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A SERIES
OF BILLS IN FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN
THOSE BILLS BUT INCLUDED SB.
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR WHICH WAS
INTENDED TO GIVE THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD DATED TO
INVESTIGATE POTENTIAL CASES OF
INAPPROPRIATE PRESCRIBING.
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR BUILT OFF
AN EXISTING DATA SHARING
AGREEMENT IN ESTABLISH A FORMAL.
ONGOING PROCESS FOR THE MEDICAL
BOARD TO BE ABLE TO REVIEW IN
CONFIDENTIALLY CONFIDENTIAL
INVESTIGATE PSYCH MADE
PRESCRIPTION PATTERNS OUTSIDE
THE STANDARD OF CARE. FOR FAST
YOU TWO BEEN ON THREE OR MORE
PSYCH MEDS FOR NINETY DAYS OR
MORE.
DH CS WOULD PROVIDE TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD THE FOLLOWING FOR
ARIES NUMBER ONE A LIST OF PSYCH
MEDS THAT WERE PRESCRIBED.
NUMBER TWO THE START AND STOP
DATES OF EACH MEDICATION THREE
THE FOSTER USE DATE OF BIRTH AND
FOR THE STRENGTH AND QUANTITY
MEDICATION.
AND THEIR NUMBER OF DAYS SUPPLY
OF MEDICATION.
MEDICAL BOARD. ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR WITHIN CONTRACT WITH AN
EXPERT PSYCHIATRISTS WHO
SPECIALIZES IN PEDIATRIC CARE TO
REVIEW THE DATA. TO DETERMINE IF
AN ACCUSATION.
OF INAPPROPRIATE PRESCRIBING
SHOULD BE MADE WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR WAS
A REALLY IMPORTANT FIRST STEP IN
PROVIDING OVERSIGHT FOR STATES
FOSTER YOUTH.
THE MEDICAL BOARD HAS SINCE
THOUGH INDICATED AND WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL TO MISS MOST WHO'S HERE
SHE'S BEEN LIVING THE DREAM ON
THIS ISSUE -- HAS INDICATED THAT
DATA SHARED -- IN THAT BILL.
DOES NOT PROVIDE ENOUGH
INFORMATION FOR THEM TO
INVESTIGATE PRESCRIBING PATTERNS
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO CRITICAL MEDICAL INFORMATION
SUCH AS THE SIMPSONS.
IN DIAGNOSIS FOR THE PSYCH MED
PRESCRIPTION.
CURRENTLY WHEN MEDICAL BOARD
FLAG THE CASE THEY WANT TO LOOK
INTO THEY MUST GO THROUGH DSS.
AS A LIAISON TO ASK FOR
PERMISSION TO CONTACT THE YOUTH.
MEDICAL BOARD PROVIDES THE SS
WITH UNIQUE IDENTIFYING NUMBER
WHICH THEN DSS MATCHES TO A NAME
OF A CURRENT OR FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH.
DSS AND I APOLOGIZE ABOUT THIS
DSS THEN SENDS A LETTER TO THE
LAST KNOWN ADDRESS OF THE FOSTER
YOUTH.
IN THE COUNTY ASKING FOR
PERMISSION TO ALLOW THE MEDICAL
BOARD TO CONTACT THE FOSTER
YOUTH.
IF DSS GETS A LETTER BACK WITH
APPROVAL CANDIDLY THAT HAS NOT
HAPPENED -- ON A REGULAR BASIS.
THE MEDICAL BOARD THEN MUST
CONTACT THE CHILD THE YOUTH
AGAIN TO ASK FOR THE
AUTHORIZATION.
THE RELEASE OF MEDICAL RECORDS.
LONG STORY SHORT.
AS YOU CAN TELL THIS PROCESS
THIS PROCESS HAS BEEN PROVEN TO
BE OVERLY CUMBERSOME -- IN THE
MEDICAL BOARD HAS BEEN UNABLE TO
CARRY OUT THEIR STATUTORY
OVERSIGHT REQUIREMENTS.
WHEN GIVEN EXAMPLE?
IN THE FIRST BATCH OF CASES THE
MEDICAL BOARD LOOKED AT THE
EXPERT FLAG THE EIGHTY SIX USE
THAT NEEDED MORE INFORMATION ON
DSS IN EIGHTY SIX LETTERS OUT.
BUT ONLY RECEIVED. FIVE FIVE
RESPONSES GIVING MEDICAL BOARD
THE AUTHORIZATION TO CONTACT THE
FOSTER YOUTH.
AFTER CONTACTING THE YOUTH
MEDICAL WERE IS ABLE TO GET
AUTHORIZATION OUT OF THOSE. FIVE
FOR THREE THIS BROKEN PROCESS IS
PROVEN INEFFECTIVE IN PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA'S FAST YOUTH FROM
OVER PRESCRIBING.
SB THREE SEVEN SEVEN WILL CUT
THROUGH THE RED TAPE IN FINDING
ALLOW THE MEDICAL BOARD TO GET
ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO CONFIDENTIALLY
INVESTIGATE.
BY GRANTING AUTHORIZATION WHEN
THE MEDICATION IS AUTHORIZED BY
THE COURTS CURRENTLY ALL CYCLE
TRIPIT MEDS FOR MINORS AND
PASSED YOUTH MUST BE APPROVED BY
A JUVENILE COURT JUDGE VIA THE
FORM J. BETWEEN. TWO TWENTY OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH ALL SIDES ON A
SOLUTION TO THIS ISSUE.
AND I'M REALLY GRATEFUL FOR ALL
SIDES WHO'VE BEEN ENGAGING IN
THIS PROCESS.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE NET
BOARD WHO IS NOW IN SUPPORT --
IN THE DEPENDENCY ATTORNEYS WHO
NOW REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION.
HERE'S HOW IT'S GONNA WORK IN
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR --
FOR YOUR LENIENCY ALLOW AND TO
BE EXPLAINED THE PROCESS AND I
APOLOGIZE TO YOU AND TO THE
MEMBERS.
SB THREE SEVEN SEVEN WILL
REQUIRE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
INCLUDE IN THEIR PSYCH MEDS
FORMS THE JB.
TWO TWENTY A REQUEST FOR
AUTHORIZATION FOR THE RELEASE OF
MEDICAL INFORMATION.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL BE REQUIRED
TO BE TO WORK WITH VERY
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING FAST
YOUTH ADVOCATES DEPENDENCY
ATTORNEYS NDSS TO ENSURE THE
REQUEST HIS **** IN A MANNER
THAT PROTECTS THE CHILD'S
MEDICAL PRIVACY.
IN ADDITION TO DRESSING NEW
CASES A POSSIBLE OVER
PRESCRIBING SB THREE SEVEN SEVEN
WILL ALSO ESTABLISH A WORKING
GROUP TO DEVELOP AN EFFECTIVE
OUT REACH METHOD. FOR FOSTER
YOUTH WHO HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
AS POTENTIAL OVER PRESCRIBED IN
THE PAST -- IT WILL ALSO ALLOW
REQUIREMENTS OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR TO BE REALIZED A
WHICH WE ALL INTENDED TO DO.
I AGAIN APOLOGIZE FOR THE
LENGTHY TESTIMONY HERE TODAY.
IT HAS BEEN A RATHER DIFFICULT I
NEED TO PEEL BACK.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR EVERYONE
INVOLVED SPECIAL YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- IN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND YOU HAVE
JENNIFER SOMOS WHO'S BEEN ON THE
FRONTLINE TO THIS ON TAKE MONTHS
TO THINKING MISS MOST.
FOR WORKING WITH US -- TWO YEARS
AGO AND AGAIN THIS YEAR ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE SHE'S HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND JUST.
EVEN THOUGH YOU HAD A LOT TO
EXPLAIN AND I THINK IT WAS
APPROPRIATE BECAUSE OF THE
DETAIL THAT WHAT WHAT THIS BILL.
REPRESENTS YOU ARE.
MAY NOT BE SURPRISED TO KNOW
WHAT YOU ARE NOT THE MOST
VERBOSE SENATOR WHO HAS APPEARED
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE -- HEY
THERE WE GO.
WITNESS PLEASE THANK YOU THIS IS
AN AD LIKE SOME OF OUR SAID
JENNIFER SOMOS WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA THE BOY LIKE
TO THINK CENTER REQUIRE
PERSISTING THE BOARD IN
OVERCOMING THE OBSTACLES THE
BOARD IS CURRENTLY FACING IN
OBTAINING THE AUTHORIZATIONS
LIKE YOU DISCUSS FOR MEDICAL
RECORDS FOR FOSTER.
YOUTH AND THE BOARD NEEDS IS
AUTHORIZATIONS FOR FOSTER YOUTH
OF THE BOARD'S EXPERT AS
IDENTIFIED AS VICTIMS OF
POTENTIAL INAPPROPRIATE
PRESCRIBING IN ORDER TO EVEN
START LOOKING AT THESE CASES --
THE RECENT ADMINS THAT WERE
TAKEN AND THE BOARD DOES HAVE A
SMALL STEP FOR STAFF AS A SMALL
TECHNICAL CONCERNED JUST WITH
THE WORDING OF THE M..
THE MEDICAL INFORMATION BEING
BROUGHT RELEVANT TO THE
PRESCRIPTION BUT WE'RE COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED AND AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO IT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TRY
ABOUT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING OF THIS YEAR AND
HANG ON JUST A SECOND LET'S GET
THE MICROPHONE TURNED ON THANK
YOU GO AHEAD.
AND THE LIVING BOMB ON BEHALF OF
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR VERY MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH US IT HAS BEEN THIS LOG WE
REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT.
WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT PRESERVING
THE RIGHTS OF THE FOSTER YOUTH
THIS CRITICAL.
OF PRESERVING THE DISCRETION THE
JUDICIAL OFFICERS.
TO ENSURE THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE CHILDREN BUT WE DEFINITELY
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING ON THIS
AND AND MAKING IT WORK SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
I THINK THAT IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
SIGNAL WITH A BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND SENATOR THANK
YOU.
FOR WEIGHING IN AND REALLY
WORKING FOR OUR FOSTER YOUTH AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE WE SEE.
CONSTRAINTS WHETHER CHEMICALS IN
THIS CASE WRITTEN PHYSICAL OFTEN
USED.
NOT IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
CHILD BUT JUST TO SORT OF KEEP
THAT CHILD COMPLY WITHIN THE
SYSTEM AND AND INDIAN.
WAY I DESCRIBE IT IN WHAT'S
BETTER FOR THE SYSTEM AND THE
MORE WE ARE CRITICAL OF SYSTEMS
IN THE MORE WERE LOOKING HARD AT
WHAT WE'RE DOING TO THOSE
CHILDREN.
THEN WE WILL GET BETTER OUTCOMES
BECAUSE WE TREAT THEM MORE
APPROPRIATELY AND FILL THEIR
NEEDS AS OPPOSED TO OUR NEEDS
AND TO ME THAT'S HOW I SEE THIS.
THE REASON FOR THE NEED FOR THIS
SO THAT I'M HOPING WE WILL
DECREASE.
THE RELIANCE ON PSYCHOTROPIC
MADS I WOULD LOVE TO GET RID OF
THOSE AS A AS A TREATMENT BUT
UNTIL WE REALLY GET A HANDLE ON
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY'RE BEING
USED AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE NOT
BEING USED INAPPROPRIATELY.
WE STILL HAVE WORK TO DO SO
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
STRESS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I DO HAVE ONE
QUESTION.
AT THE END OF THE ANALYSIS THE
LAST QUESTION SAYS IT APPEARS
THE BILL AS NOW IN PRINT SHOULD
DRESSY OPPONENTS CONCERNS
ALTHOUGH THE OPPONENTS HAVE NOT
EXPRESSED THAT THEMSELVES.
HAS THAT -- HAS THAT -- TAKEN
AWAY THE OPPONENTS CONCERNS.
I CANNOT SAY THAT WERE ALWAYS
GOING TO HAVE A 100% SUPPORT SO
I'LL GIVE EXAMPLE AND I DON'T
KNOW WHERE THEY'RE AT BUT SAID
THE CHILD PSYCHOLOGISTS HAVE
BEEN OPPOSE THEIR OPPOSED TO OUR
REGIONAL BORE.
ELEVEN BROUGH BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR I DON'T KNOW WHERE
THEY'RE AT I ASSUME THEY MAY
STILL BE OPPOSED -- ON THIS
ISSUE -- BUT AS FAR AS THE
DEPENDENCY ATTORNEYS THERE NOW
WHO WERE IN OPPOSITION THEY NOW
HAVE REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION
MEDICAL BOARD HAS -- COMBINED
SUPPORT IN THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
IS NEUTRAL AND HAVE BEEN
ACTIVELY ENGAGE ON THIS ISSUE.
I AND I DO WANT TAKE MOMENT --
ADAM SILLY WOMAN IF THAT'S OKAY
JUST TO SAY THANK YOU BECAUSE
THEY HAVE EXPRESSED SOME
CONCERNS I DO WANT TO SPEAK FOR
THEM AND WE'VE BEEN.
ACTIVELY ENGAGE WITH THEM TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS
TO KEEP THE THE AUTHORITY OF A
JUDGE IN TACT WHILE ALSO
ENSURING THAT THE MEDICAL BOARD
GETS THE INFORMATION.
BUT WE DIDN'T HAVE ANYONE HERE
SPEAKING -- IN OPPOSITION I
CAN'T TELL YOU THAT FOLKS HER
PRISON ARE STILL ALL RIGHT NOT
TO POST.
SPECIFICALLY THE THESE CMA.
ARE THEY NOW NEUTRAL.
I DON'T KNOW OKAY AND I
APOLOGIZE.
IT'S TELLING THAT THERE WAS NO
TESTIMONY IN A POSITION TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
RIGHT SEEN ON SENATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR VERY GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP ON THIS AND
MANY OTHER ISSUES -- DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK FROM ALL
SIDES DID YOU JUST COUNCIL MET
BOARDING ALSO ONE TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO DANIEL
BRADLEY FROM OUR OFFICE.
WHO'S BEEN THE GO BETWEEN AND
PRAY GRATEFUL FOR HER WORK AS
WELL AND WAS BACK RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIGHT.
THANK YOU SENATOR WAS SELENA
MOTION MOTIONS TO PASS TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CHAU CHIU GONZALEZ.
CONSULT AYE HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS PRESS.
REYES AYE.
THANK YOU.
THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
RICHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT IF WE COULD OUR LAST
ITEM TO BE HEARD IS SENATOR
WIENER SPELL WE DO HAVE MORE
MEMBERS HERE SO I'D LIKE TO GO
THROUGH.
THE AGENDA MOST OF THE ITEMS ARE
ON CALL.
SO LET'S START WITH THE CONSENT
AGENDA I'M GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL.
SOME MEMBERS GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CHAU CHIU HOLDEN
KALRA.
COVER AYE OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS.
THOSE BILLS ARE OUT THAT IS SB
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN Y. KOWSKI SB
THREE OF SIX MARROW.
SB FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT JONES AND
SB.
SIX FIFTY TWO ALAN.
ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA LIVE THE
CALL ON ITEM NUMBER TWO SB ONE
SEVENTY ONE JACKSON CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHAU CHIU.
HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA I OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
THAT IS.
STILL ON CALL ME REPLACE THE
CALL FIVE NUMBER THREE SB TWO
TWENTY TWO ON THE LIST THE CALL.
GALLAGHER.
HI GALLAGHER I CHAO CHIU.
HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
NORRIS.
THAT IS I WOULD REPLACE THE CALL
WE STILL NEED ONE VOTE ON THAT.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB THREE
EIGHTEEN HERTZBERG I'M GONNA LET
THE CALL GALLAGHER.
CHAO TO HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS.
THAT IS STILL A CALL ME REPLACE
THE CALL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB THREE TWENTY
SIX CENTER HILL IS ON CALL I'M
GONNA LIVE THE CALL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CHOW H..
GALLAGHER I CHAU CHIU.
HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA I OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS.
THAT IS THE LOCALLY NEEDS ONE
MORE I'M GOING TO REPLACE THE
CALL.
RIGHT IF WE COULD GETS.
SENATOR WINNER HERE WE'LL BE
ABLE TO WRAP UP OUR COMMITTEE
TODAY
ALL RIGHT GIVEN THAT THE
SENATORS PRESENTING IN BUSINESS
IMPRESSIONS.
LET'S TAKE A RECESS UNTIL TEN
FORTY FIVE GIVE EVERYBODY A
CHANCE.
TO PLEASE COME BACK SO WE CAN
FINISH UP ONCE WE GET THIS ONE
STARTED SO WE ARE NOW IN RECESS
.
WELCOME SENATOR WIENER ALRIGHT
WE ARE [inaudible]
BACK.
INACTION WE'RE GONNA TAKE OF OUR
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB.
FORTY WE ARE HERE AT YOUR
DISPOSAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
APOLOGIES.
FOR HAVING TO PRESENT TOO MANY
BILLS THIS MORNING -- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE -- AND I WANT
TO THANK -- THE CHAIRMAN IS
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH US OVER THE LAST
MONTH ON THIS BILL AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES --
AMENDMENTS WHICH HAVE BEEN MADE
THANK YOU STRONG AT THE THE BILL
HERE IS JUST. TO PASS A BECAUSE
THE AMENDMENTS ARE IMPRENSA
RIDES BUT THAT'S THE WORK
ALREADY SPENT ON OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS YES THANK YOU --
SO OUR COLLEAGUES AT THIS BILL --
IT MIGHT SEEM FAMILIAR BECAUSE
LAST YEAR THIS COMMITTEE PASSED --
AND THE LEGISLATURE PASSED IN
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED SB TEN FORTY
FIVE I TO CREATE A NEW HOUSING
CONSERVATORSHIP AS A PILOT
PROGRAM.
IN SAN FRANCISCO LOS ANGELES AND
SAN DIEGO COUNTIES -- TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THE VERY REAL A CRISIS
THAT IS UNFOLDING ON OUR STREETS
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE SEVERELY
MENTALLY ILL SEVERELY.
ADDICTED -- AND WHO ARE
UNRAVELLING AND LITERALLY DYING
ON OUR STREETS -- THIS IS ABOUT
A VERY RELATIVELY SMALL.
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
CAPABLE OF ACCEPTING VOLUNTARY
SERVICES AND WHO WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO REACH -- THROUGH
TRADITIONAL OFFERING A VOLUNTARY.
SERVICES AND WE OWE IT TO THEM --
TO SAVE THEIR LIVES -- AND SO SB --
FORTY IS -- AND A FOLLOW UP TO
SB TEN FORTY FIVE THE BILL THAT
IS BEFORE YOU TODAY -- IS --
TIGHTER IN TERMS OF PROCESS --
IT IS MORE PROTECTIVE THAN OF
CIVIL LIBERTIES EVEN THEN SB --
TEN FORTY FIVE WAS -- AS WITH
TEN SB TEN FORTY FIVE AND
EXISTING CONSERVATORSHIP LAWS
HAS STRONG STRONG DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS IN TERMS OF JUDICIAL
OVERSIGHT -- PEOPLE GETTING
ACCESS TO A DEFENSE ATTORNEY IN
SAN FRANCISCO FOR EXAMPLE THAT
THE PUBLIC DEFENDER -- AND THE
BILL -- REALLY DEEPLY PROTECTS
PEOPLE CIVIL LIBERTIES WHILE
ALSO CREATING A NEW TOOL TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE SAVING PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
ON THE BILL -- REQUIRES VARIOUS
STOPS IN ORDER FOR THIS
CONSERVATORSHIP TO APPLY IT YOU
CANNOT EVEN BE CONSIDERED FOR
THIS CONSERVATORSHIP UNLESS YOU
HAVE BEEN FIFTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT
TIMES.
IN A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD A
MINIMUM OF EIGHT TIMES ON SOME
PEOPLE ASK ME WHAT OUT ONE APPLY
TO ANYONE UNFORTUNATELY IT DOES
APPLY TO PEOPLE BECAUSE THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THAT LEVEL.
OF CRISIS -- BILL REQUIRES --
IT'S A STEP INCREASE -- AFTER
THE EIGHT FIFTY ONE FIFTIES
THERE'S A TWENTY EIGHT DAY
TEMPORARY CONSERVATORSHIP -- AND
THEN -- AFTER POTENTIALLY A
THIRD JUDGE TRIAL OR JURY TRIAL
IF ONE'S REQUESTED -- IT CAN BE
EXTENDED AS FAR AS LONG AS SIX
MONTHS -- THIS IS SHORTENING THE
CONSERVATORSHIP FROM LAST YEAR
SB TEN FORTY FIVE PROVIDE UP TO
A YEAR -- THE MAXIMUM IS NOW --
SIX MONTHS -- THE BILL MAKES OUR
VARIOUS -- CLARIFYING.
AMENDMENTS AROUND ASSISTED
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT -- TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO WILL NOT
BENEFIT WHO ARE NOT MEDICALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR A T. ARE NOT BEING
FORCED INTO A T. -- AND THE BILL
MAKES OTHER CLARIFICATIONS
SOUGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT -- THIS
CONSERVATORSHIP CAN ACTUALLY.
BE IMPLEMENTED I WANT TO BE VERY
VERY CLEAR AND I RESPECT THE
OPPOSITION THIS BILL I WILL SAY
THAT OVER THE COURSE OF LAST
YEAR AND A HALF -- THE
OPPOSITION WANT TO THANK THEM
FOR KNOWLEDGE BEING THAT FROM
THEIR PERSPECTIVE -- THE BILL IS --
WELL THEY DON'T SUPPORT IT IS
LESS PROBLEMATIC FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE THAN IT WAS.
BEFORE AND WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
NOW THIS COMMITTEE -- TO TRY TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS -- WHILE STILL
HAVING AN EFFECTIVE.
PROGRAM THIS IS A TOOL OF LAST
RESORT -- THIS IS A TOOL TO BE
USED FOR PEOPLE FOR WHOM WE HAVE
BEEN ON ABLE TO HELP.
WITH TRADITIONAL VOLUNTARY
SERVICES I'M A HUGE SUPPORTER OF
VOLUNTARY SERVICES THAT IS
ALWAYS THE PER HEARD APPROACH.
BY IN A TINY PERCENTAGE OF CASES
VOLUNTARY SERVICES SIMPLY AREN'T
WORKING -- AND PEOPLE ARE
DETERIORATING AND DYING SO I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF FROM CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS -- IN SAN FRANCISCO
DID RECENTLY VOTE -- ALMOST
UNANIMOUSLY TO OPT IN BECAUSE IT
IS AN OPT IN FOR THE PILOT
COUNTIES I WOULD BE TO THEIR
DAUGHTER ANGELICA ALMEIDA WHO
THE DIRECTOR OF THE FORENSIC AND
JUSTICE INVOLVED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES AT THE SAN
FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH --
AND CAPTAIN AYE CAPTAIN KNEELS --
TANGO SORRY THANK YOU LET ME
TAKE A LEVY WHO'S THE SECOND
CHIEF OF THE EMMAUS OPERATION AT
SAN FRANCISCO FIRE DEPARTMENT.
WE WE WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND WE
DO HAVE A SECOND FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR SENATE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DOCTOR ANGELIC HELL MADE AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR FRIENDS AGAIN JUST
AS INVOLVED BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SERVICES FOR THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO.
INCLUDING PROGRAMS SUCH AS
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
AND COORDINATION FOR LPS
CONSERVATORSHIP.
ON BEHALF OF MAYOR BREED AND THE
SITTING COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
HEARING THIS BILL AND I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR SCOTT WIENER FOR
ITS CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
LEADERSHIP IN CALLING ATTENTION
TO THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
WE ARE STRUGGLING WITH A MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE CRISIS
ON OUR STREETS AND ACROSS OUR
STATE AND COUNTRY.
AND THERE ARE MANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND ARE SUFFERING
FROM BOTH MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE NEEDS. FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS THE REALITY IS A SAD
REPEATING CYCLE WHERE PEOPLE ARE
LIVING ON THE STREET.
GOING IN AND OUT OF EMERGENCY
ROOMS AND IN SOME CASES BEING
ARRESTED OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THIS IS DAMAGING TO THEIR HEALTH
AND OVERALL WELL BEING.
AS A PROVIDER I CAN SURE THAT
THESE ARE THE CASES I STRUGGLE
ARE AN ADEQUATE TO SUPPORT AND
STABILIZE THEM.
LAST YEAR GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED
AS BE TEN FORTY FIVE WHICH
CREATES AN OPTIONAL NEW
CONSERVATORSHIP.
AND THE LAST NUMBER OF MONTHS AS
WE STARTED TO PREPARE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB TEN FORTY
FIVE WE'VE IDENTIFIED A FEW
AREAS OF THE BILL THAT NEED SOME
MODIFICATION TO ENSURE WE CAN
SERVE THE POPULATION THAT WE
INTENDED TO SERVE.
SB FORTY INCLUDE THOSE
MODIFICATIONS REINFORCES THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF SB TEN FORTY
FIVE AND OFFERS AS A WAY TO
REACH IN SUPPORT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS.
IT DOES NOT EXPAND THE
POPULATION OF INDIVIDUALS
ELIGIBLE FOR HOUSING
CONSERVATORSHIP WHICH IN SAN
FRANCISCO THE NUMBER IS
ESTIMATED TO BE BETWEEN FIFTY
AND SEVENTY FIVE OUR CITY HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF BEING INNOVATIVE
AND PROVIDING COMPASSIONATE CARE
AND NEITHER I AND MY COLLEAGUES
OR MAYOR BREED TO TAKE.
LIGHTLY THE IDEA OF LIMITING
ANYONE CIVIL LIBERTIES.
WE SHOULD ALWAYS TRY TO HELP
PEOPLE IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
WAY IT IS OUR MORAL ETHICAL AND
LEGAL OBLIGATION BUT WE MUST NOT
TURN OUR BACKS ON THOSE IN NEED
AND I'M HERE BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
CHANCE TO MAKE A MEANINGFUL
DIFFERENCE.
AND WITH THIS COMMITTEE SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL FORTY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DOING JUST THAT.
I WANT TO THANK CHAIR STONE AND
THIS ENTIRE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS WITH.
THE MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS NEIL STINGER LEANING AND
I'M THE EMS OPERATIONS CHIEF FOR
THE SAN FRANCISCO FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
I IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR WAS MY
HONOR TO HELP THE DEPARTMENT IN
THE CITY START THE FIRST THE MS
BASED OUT REACH PROGRAM.
WAS CALLED THE HOME TEAM --
PARTING WITH OTHER CLINICIANS WE
WENT OUT IN THE STREETS TO TRY
TO CONNECT FREQUENT USERS OF THE
EN MASSE TO OTHER SYSTEMS OF
CARE.
I WHAT QUICKLY BECAME APPARENT
THAT AND IT'S STILL TRUE TODAY
IS THAT FIRST SMALL SEGMENT OF
THIS POPULATION.
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS HAS%
GONE UNTREATED FOR TOO LONG OR
WITH ADDICTION HAS DESTROYED
THEIR COGNITIVE ABILITIES.
NO AMOUNT OF ENGAGEMENT SERVICES
AND NO OFFER OF SERVICES WOULD
DO ANYTHING TO CHANGE THE
SITUATION -- I REMEMBER ONE
CLIENT WHO -- BECAUSE OF HIS
DRINKING IS MENTAL ILLNESS
EVENTUALLY HE FOUND HE WAS OUT
ON THE STREETS.
AND DESPITE OUR EFFORTS TO
ENGAGE WITH HIM DESPITE REPEATED
TRIPS THROUGH DETOX AND HUNDREDS
OF TRIPS TO THE ER HE EVENTUALLY
WAS FOUND FROZEN LEANING AGAINST
THE POLE -- THIS GENTLEMAN WAS
IN HIS EARLY THIRTIES -- ANOTHER
CLIENT THAT I WOULD GO AND
ENGAGE WITH A LOT -- WE SPEND
HIS DAYS AGGRESSIVELY
PANHANDLING AND SMOKING CRACK
COCAINE UNTIL EMS WAS CALLED.
WOULD FIND HIM A MAN MISSING ONE
OF ITS HOLD BOB RIGHT LEG --
WOULD FIND HIM SITTING NEXT TO
STE WHEELCHAIR COVERED IN FECES
AND IN A PSYCHOTIC RAGE AND WE
WE DO THIS AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN -- TODAY WITH CODIFY THOSE
EARLY EFFORTS -- IN THE FORM OF
COMMUNITY PARAMEDICS WE HAVE NOW --
AND PILOTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THE CHALLENGE FACED BY THESE
CARE GIVERS THAT MIGHT MY
COLLEAGUES ARE MAGNIFIED TODAY
BY THIS GROWING OPIOID IN
METHAMPHETAMINE CRISIS WE SEE
ALL AROUND THE NATION -- SOME OF
OUR CLIENTS HAVE UTILIZED NINE
ONE TWO TO THREE HUNDRED TIMES
IN A SINGLE YEAR -- ONE CLIENT
WE HAD A DIABETIC WHO IS ALSO A
METHAMPHETAMINE USER WHO
INTERACTED WITH FREQUENTLY HAD
BEEN TRANSPORTED NEARLY A
HUNDRED TIMES IN THE FEW MONTHS
BEFORE HE DIED IN ONE OF OUR
YARDS.
SO WE DESPERATELY NEED SB TEN
FORTY FIVE IN SB FORTY AS A
MEANS OF STOPPING THIS TRAGIC
AND UNNECESSARY DEATHS ON THE
STREETS.
YEAH PLEASE HELP OUR COMMUNITY
PARAMEDICS AS THEY GO OUT THERE
IN THE FIELD TO DO THIS WORK FOR
OUR MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND AND
CONSIDERATION FOR SB.
FORTY THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
COME FOR GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE --
MISTER CHAMBERS MATTHEW SO I
REALLY ONLY HAVE THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE COMMAND
THE CENTER FOR HIS HARD WORK ON
THIS ISSUE AND HE'S.
YOU KNOW APPROPRIATELY DESCRIBE
THIS IS A CRISIS ME TO ASK THIS
BILL THE PAST THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RANDALL HAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
IN A SECOND SALAS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE THEIR OPPOSITION
.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CURTAILED
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
VERY THOROUGH YOU.
ANALYSIS THAT THEY DID -- BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY I THINK QUE IN
DOING THE ANALYSIS REALLY SORTED
THROUGH I THINK SOME OF THE KEY
ISSUES THAT WERE BLATANTLY
PROBLEMATIC WITH THE SB FORTY
AND WITH THE AMENDMENTS -- I
THINK WE DO AGREE THAT THAT HAS
MADE -- IT THE BILL LESS
PROBLEMATIC THAN IT HAS -- IN
THE PAST -- IT IN AS YOU NOTE
THAT A COUPLE KEY PIECES FOR US
IS HE DID SHORTEN -- THE LENGTH
OF THE TEMPORARY --
CONSERVATORSHIP -- IT DOES
INCLUDE NOW MORE NOTICES TO
INDIVIDUALS AT THE TIME OF FIFTY
ONE FIFTIES -- TO ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO KNOW
THAT.
AT THE END OF THESE -- EIGHT
SHOULD THAT -- ULTIMATELY HAPPEN
THAT TO A CONSERVATORSHIP WOULD
RESULT -- AND I THINK CRITICALLY
WOOD IS IMPORTANT IS INDEED A
THOROUGH EVALUATION WOULD NOW
TAKE PLACE UNDER THIS BILL UP
FRONT -- THAT WASN'T HAPPENING
BEFORE WE CERTAINLY KNOW FIFTY
ONE FIFTIES ARE NOT A THOROUGH
EVALUATION THAT THAT IS A PERSON
YOU KNOW ESSENTIALLY GETTING
TOUCHED ON THE STREET PRIDE AND
FOR SEVENTY TWO HOURS THIS
PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY -- FOR
BUT WE THINK TO THE IMPORTANT AT
AND NEEDED -- CHANCE FOR THE
EVALUATION -- AND WE ALSO THINK
THAT THE OPPORTUNITY AND IT'S
VERY PLEASED TO HEAR -- CENTER
WINNING SAY ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF VOLUNTARY TREATMENT AND SO
THAT -- ROOT REQUIRING NOW THE
COUNTY TO INDEED OFFER VOLUNTARY
TREATMENT -- BEFORE EACH
DETENTION AFTER THE THIRD FIFTY
ONE FIFTY IS -- IS GOING TO BE --
CRITICAL -- AND WE ALSO ARE VERY --
PLEASED TO SEE THAT THERE IS A
COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION -- AT
THE END OF THE PILOT AND I THINK
THAT WILL PROVIDE SOME
SIGNIFICANT INFORMATION -- ON
OUTCOMES -- OF SUCH A NEW
PROPOSAL THAT -- WE THINK LIMITS
ON THE LIBERTIES OF OF
INDIVIDUALS BUT WITH ALL OF THAT
BEING SAID WE DO REMAIN --
OPPOSED TO THE TO THE BILL AND
AND FOR THE REASONS THAT WE HAVE
REPEATEDLY SAID THAT THE THE
BILL.
LIKE TEN FORTY FIVE DOES TAKE
AWAY INDIVIDUAL FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS AND LIBERTIES THAT FOLKS
HAVE NOW UNDER -- THE CURRENT
LAW WHICH I THINK -- HAS QUITE
FAIRLY ADEQUATELY BALANCED
IMPORTANT CRITICAL FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS WITH A NEED -- FOR CARE --
FOR FOR DECADES AND WE'D SUGGEST
THAT THIS BILL DOESN'T HAVE --
THAT BALANCE -- THE THE OTHER --
ITEM THAT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
IS THERE'S REALLY NO LIMITATION
ON THE POTENTIAL NUMBER OF
PERSONS THAT.
ARE POTENTIALLY SUBJECT TO TO
THIS IT'S BEEN -- IN OUR OPINION
MOSTLY GAS ALONG THE WAY GUESS
GUESSES -- ALONG THE WAY ON WHAT
THAT NUMBER WOULD BE IT STARTED
OFF -- LOWER -- I THINK IS
HEARING THE NUMBER NOW 527-5 AND
WE'VE HEARD THE NUMBER -- FROM --
FROM ADVOCATES -- IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN THIS THAT -- COULD
POTENTIALLY BE -- A HUNDRED OR
MORE BUT WE DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER HOW MANY -- THAT COULD --
POTENTIALLY -- BE -- ALSO --
WHAT WE'D HAVE ADVOCATED
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS AND TEN
FORTY FIVE AND IN THIS BILL --
IS WELL IS THERE ARE NO
RESOURCES -- THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING THERE IS NO
RESOURCES -- FOR ADDITIONAL
SERVICES THAT ARE GUARANTEED BY --
THIS BILL -- AND I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHRONICLE CONTINUES TO REPORT ON
WHAT THEY HAVE SEEN AS A BROKEN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM IN THE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS
RIGHT NOW.
OF RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WE THINK THAT THAT
ULTIMATELY MEANS THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL -- BE BRIAN
AND CONSERVED UNDER THIS NEW
PROVISION ARE GOING TO END UP IN
THE INSTITUTIONS AND POTENTIALLY
LOCKED INSTITUTIONS FOR A FOR
THE CHARACTER SO AGAIN WE
BELIEVE THAT THE ANSWER IS --
PROVIDING FIX SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES UP FRONT THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED TO TRY THAT'S WHAT WE NEED
TO TEST THOSE NEED TO BE.
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING THEY NEED TO
BE TREATMENT -- AND SERVICES ALL
OFFERED IN THE COMMUNITY AND NOT
IN INSTITUTIONS AND SO FOR THAT
REASON WE ARE CHORE -- NO VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
GOOD MORNING CHEN FLOOR ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY -- I AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE AT
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA --
FOR WESTERN CENTER THE INITIAL
BILL SB TEN FORTY FIVE AND SB
FORTY ARE STILL VERY MUCH
FOCUSED ON STATUS RATHER THAN
CONDITION WHETHER IT WAS THE
ORIGINAL THIS IS A HOMELESS
CONSERVATORSHIP OR IT'S YOU KNOW
NOW BASED ON HISTORY OF ARRESTOR
FIFTY ONE FIFTIES -- IT'S REALLY
BASED ON SOMEBODY STATUS AT IN
CALIFORNIA THE HISTORY OF THE
IMPACT OF CONFINEMENT IS NOT
GOOD WHETHER IT'S IN PRISONS OR
IT CONFINED IN HOSPITALS WE TEND
TO CONFINE POOR PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR -- AND WE ALSO
REMAIN YOU KNOW CONCERNED ABOUT
THE REMOVAL OF A TIAS
REQUIREMENTS.
THAT SAID I WOULD YOU KNOW I DO
AGREE WITH THAT SENATOR -- THERE
IS A CRISIS OUR ANSWER TO THE
CRISIS IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
HOUSING FIRST WITH FULL OF
WRAPAROUND SERVICES AS NECESSARY.
THAT SAID I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR AMENDS
WE BELIEVE THAT THE ADDITIONAL --
DUE PROCESS REQUIREMENTS MAY
ACTUALLY HELP MORE PEOPLE GET
THE SERVICES THAT THEY SHOULD BE
GETTING -- AND WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT THAT'S THE CASE AND FINALLY
WE THINK THAT THE EVALUATION
PIECE THAT WAS ADDED IS CRITICAL --
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE WE OFTEN
HAVE A DISPARATE IMPACT WHEN IT
COMES TO CONFINEMENT SO WE'RE
GLAD THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY TRACK AND LOOK AT THAT --
AS WELL AS DETERMINE WHETHER THE
CONSERVATORSHIP SAYS PLANNED ARE
WORKING OUT AS INTENDED NONE THE
LESS AS I MENTIONED WE REMAIN
OPPOSED AND I REQUEST YOU KNOW
ABOUT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
IF YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE TURN
MEMBERS KEVIN BANK OF AMERICA
THE CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION OF
CALIFORNIA WITH RESPECT AND
APPRECIATION FOR THE COMMITTEE
AND THE AUTHOR.
WE NEVER LEFT FOR ME TO POST
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS WERE NAY
BAYARDO AS HE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
WE APPRECIATE AMENDMENTS AS WELL
THERE'S A LOT OF PROGRESS NEVER
WE REMAIN OPPOSED.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THIS RACE THE MISTER KALRA.
THIS IS PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT OF BILLS THAT.
THE WE HAVE.
TO BUT I HAVE TO VOTE ON BECAUSE
THE OPPOSITION THESE ARE THE
THESE ARE THE VERY ORGANIZATIONS
THAT I AM ALWAYS AND AGREE WITH
AN AGREEMENT WITH.
I APPRECIATE THAT SENATOR WINNER
THAT YEAR THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL -- BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE COMMITTED TO THIS AS WELL
AND YOU'RE TRYING TO FIND.
THE THE SOLUTIONS TO SOMETHING
THAT THAT EVERYBODY AGREES IS A
CRISIS WE ARE AT THE END OF IT
TO PUT IN A POINT NOW WHERE
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE.
AND ALTHOUGH IT EVERY TIME WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TAKING AWAY THE
CIVIL LIBERTIES OF ANY HUMAN
BEING WE'VE GOT TO TREAD LIGHTLY
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE DUE
PROCESS IS THERE.
AND I TO APPRECIATE THE
VALUATION PIECE AND I THINK THAT
THAT IS GOING TO LEAD TO MORE
SERVICES BEING PROVIDED BEFORE
THE NEXT STEP IS TAKEN -- I I
APPRECIATE ALSO THE YOUR COMMENT
ABOUT USING THIS AS A TOOL.
OF LAST RESORT -- AND DID MAKING
SURE THAT WE HELP PEOPLE.
IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE WAY --
IT IT IS A DIFFICULT ONE I I AM
WITH YOU THOUGH I DO THINK THAT
WHEN WE HAVE TRIED EVERYTHING WE
ALSO -- WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO THOSE WHO ARE MOST IN NEED
AND ARE ABLE.
TO FIND HOW. TO TO TO TAKE CARE
OF THEMSELVES.
BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL THE DUE PROCESS IS THERE AND
THAT WE PROTECT THEM FROM.
THOSE OVER ZEALOUS -- PEOPLE WHO
SIMPLY WANT THEM OFF THE STREETS
AND WANT THEM PUT AWAY --
WITHOUT HAVING TO DEAL WITH THEM
AGAIN.
BUT TO TO FIND A WAY. TO TO TO
TAKE CARE OF THEM.
IT'S THIS IS THIS IS A TOUGH.
ONE BUT I APPRECIATE.
COMMENTS FROM THE OPPOSITION
BECAUSE I THINK IT MADE THIS
BILL A LOT BETTER -- WITH MORE
PROTECTIONS -- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THIS CAR.
YEAH I AM.
I JOIN UP WITH MY COLLEAGUE IN --
THIS IS A DIFFICULT I KNOW IT'S
NOT EASY FOR YOU CENTER WIENER
BECAUSE IT IS I KNOW WHERE YOUR
COMPASSION YOUR SENSIBILITIES
LIE -- BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND --
IT WILL BE WE HAVE A CRISIS IN
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS.
AND I THINK ALL OF US AGREE THAT
WE NEED MORE SUPPORT OF HOUSING
AND THAT'S SOMETHING YOU I AND I
THINK MANY OF US UP HERE
SUPPORTED.
AS WELL -- AND END IN ON AND AND
FRANKLY.
YOU KNOW IN MY PAST LIFE I HAVE
CLIENTS THAT I PROBABLY WISH I
COULD OF CONSERVED BUT I'M GLAD
I DIDN'T HAVE THE POWER TO THE
GOVERNMENT DIDN'T HAVE THE POWER
TO SO IT'S IT'S IT'S A REALLY --
I THINK THAT THE FACT AND I
THINK THAT THE OPPOSITION
INDICATES THE THE AMENDMENT
CERTAINLY MAKE IT A BETTER BILL
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF A DUE
PROCESS AND THAT THE PERSPECTIVE.
OF ENSURING THAT TO THE THE
SCOPE IS LIMITED -- BUT BY THE
GOVERNMENT -- BUT ULTIMATELY IT
IS THE GOVERNMENT THAT WERE
GIVEN THE ABILITY -- TO TAKE A
LIBERTIES AWAY AND I YOU KNOW.
I I KNOW THAT -- IT IN I THINK
THE OFTENTIMES -- BUT WITH BILLS
LIKE THIS WERE CLEARLY I MEAN
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
A LOT OF PAIN.
THAT -- CAN ASK FOR HELP AND
NEED HELP -- AND SO THE
INTENTIONS -- I BELIEVE ARE A
100% GENUINE OF CERTAINLY FROM
YOU SENATOR -- IT'S UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SPECIALNESS
POLITICAL PRESSURE.
AND MANY OF THESE JURISDICTIONS
TO KIND OF CLEAR THE STREETS. TO
BEAUTIFY GET RID OF THE WHOLE
BLIGHT.
THAT'S WHERE I GET WORRIED
THAT'S WHY THESE CHECKS AND
BALANCES IN THE REVIEWS AND THAT
THE DATA COLLECTION ON
DEMOGRAPHICS ARE ALL GOING TO BE
CRITICAL IN AND I REALLY LOOK AT
THIS -- AS A TRUE PILOT I I KNOW
THAT OFTENTIMES PILOTS ARE PUT
IN PLACE AND THEN IT GETS TO THE
END OKAY LET'S MAKE A PERMANENT
NOW -- YOU KNOW I THINK MANY OF
US -- WILL LIKELY STILL BE HERE.
WHEN WHEN THE WHEN THE PILOT?
A COMES TO A CONCLUSION.
AND I'LL BE -- IF IF MY SUPPORT
CONTINUES FOR THE BILL AT THE
I'M I'M DROPPING IN THE BE
LOOKING VERY CAREFULLY -- AT THE
DATA AND I KNOW THE OPPOSITION
ON I KNOW YOU WILL AS WELL A
CENTER -- AND I THINK THAT TO
REALLY SEE IT HAS THE DESIRED
OUTCOME OF ACTUALLY HELPING.
THOSE -- THAT OUR CONCERT AND
NOT JUST SIMPLY WAREHOUSING
PEOPLE AND GETTING THEM OUT OF
SIGHT OUT OF MIND.
BECAUSE THAT'S ALWAYS THE WORRY
WHENEVER THERE'S WELL
INTENTIONED BILLS AND IN THE
HISTORY WE HAVE.
IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN THIS
NATION IS IS NOT A GOOD -- ONE
BUT AGAIN GIVEN THE FACT THAT.
SPEARHEADING IT GIVES ME SOME
SENSE OF COMFORT -- AND THE FACT
THAT IT'S AN THREE JURISDICTIONS
AND CAN BE MONITORED AS SUCH --
INTO ANIMAL IN A MORE NARROW
SCOPE AS OPPOSED TO A STATEWIDE
PILOT -- AND THREE JURISDICTIONS
I KNOW THAT HAVE BEEN.
FACING A LOT OF ISSUES IN TERMS
OF CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS AND AND
ISSUES OF OF OF IT IN IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES -- BUT I WAS AS A
STATE OF BY -- BY OPPOSITION YOU
KNOW THAT THE THE THE STATUS OF
OTHER THE HOMELESS OR OF BEING
AN INCONVENIENCE OR ALONE --
CANNOT BE THE JUSTIFICATION TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS TYPE OF
ACTION SO -- AGAIN I'LL I'LL
REPEAT THAT OF ITEMS IN SUPPORT
OF THE COMMENTS FROM OPPOSITION
THAT.
THE AMENDMENTS I THINK
DEFINITELY MAKE IT A BETTER BILL --
AND I HONESTLY LOOK FORWARD TO
THE FEEDBACK WE GET BACK AND IN
THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS TO SEE --
IF IT PASSES BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S
URGENCY BECAUSE WHAT YEAH
THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THERE BUT
CERTAINLY IF IT IS ABLE TO GET
PASSING IT SIGNED INTO LAW.
WE'LL BE LOOKING VERY CLOSELY IN
AND I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES A SAM
CISCO IN THESE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS LA SAN DIEGO WILL
ALSO BE LOOKING VERY CLOSELY SO
I HAVE SOME SENSE OF COMFORT OF
OF FOLKS THAT.
I LINE WITH VERY MUCH
IDEOLOGICALLY THEY'RE ALWAYS
GOING TO BE PAYING CLOSE
ATTENTION TO THE CIVIL LIBERTY
ISSUES HERE SO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES MAIENSCHEIN.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN I RAN OVER HERE TO IT
BECAUSE I I REALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU AND AND GIVE SOME KUDOS THE
AUTHOR THIS IS THIS IS A REALLY --
DIFFICULT SUBJECT WHEN I WAS AT
THE HOMELESS MEASURE FOR SAN
DIEGO.
AND WORKING WITH -- THE THE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS A SERIOUSLY
MENTALLY ILL IS FINDING THAT
BALANCE BECAUSE WE HAD THESE
ISSUES WHERE -- THE LEGAL
REMEDIES STEP TO TO BEGIN TO
HELP SOME THESE TWO AND WAS IT
WASN'T JUST THE HOMELESS IT WAS
ALMOST PROVIDERS TO BUT PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN LONG TERM HOMELESS.
NO WHAT DO YOU DO TO BEGIN TO
HELP THEM -- AND WHAT SORT OF
DEFINES WHAT IS BEING HUMANE.
YOU KNOW AT SOME POINT IT'S YOU
KNOW IT'S IT'S IN MY VIEW IT'S
NOT HUMANE TO LET'S TO HAVE TO
NOT HAVE -- PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
TO SOMEBODY WHO HAS.
CLEARLY -- SHOWN PARTICULAR
THROUGH MENTAL ILLNESS AND AN
ABILITY TO CARE FOR THEMSELVES
AND ABILITY TO MAKE DECISIONS
THAT WOULD.
IMPROVE THEIR LOT AND SO -- I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A SENSITIVE
LEGAL ISSUE.
BUT I THINK AT THE END OF THE
DAY THE GOOD -- TREMENDOUSLY
OUTWEIGHS THE BAD AND IT'S A WAY
TO START -- WRAPPING HER ARMS
AROUND AND HELPING IT.
WITHOUT QUESTION THE MOST
VULNERABLE OF ANIMALS SO THANK
YOU FOR TACKLING THIS UNIT HAD
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS -- YOU KNOW
FOR MANY YEARS WHY AFFECT MY
FIRST MET THIS IS THE TOPIC THAT
REALLY KIND OF CAME UP AND SO.
I THANK YOU FOR TACKLING IT IT'S
IT'S DIFFICULT I'M I'M PLEASED
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY AND I THINK
IT'LL GO.
A LONG WAY TOWARDS HELPING SOME
OF OUR SEEMINGLY INTRACTABLE
PROBLEMS [inaudible]
THIS GALLAGHER.
YES SUPPORTED YOUR BILL LAST
YEAR AND I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY YES I THINK THAT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS.
WE CAN'T JUST KEEP DOING THE
SAME OLD THING AND EXPECTING
DIFFERENT RESULTS WE HAVE TO TRY
SOME DIFFERENT THINGS AND I
THINK THIS THIS PILOT PROGRAM IN
ENSURING THAT IT CAN BE
EFFECTIVE -- BY DOING THESE
CHANGES TODAY.
YOU ARE OUR BY THE DIRECTION WE
NEED TO MOVE IN AND I THINK IT'S
BEEN STATED BY OTHERS TODAY THAT.
MANY OF THESE ISSUES UNLESS YOU
YOU KNOW.
TRULY DEAL WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH OR DRUG ADDICTION ISSUE.
THAT PERSON IS GOING TO CONTINUE
BE BACK ON THE STREETS.
THERE IS NO EASY ANSWERS.
CERTAINLY IN DEALING WITH -- YOU
KNOW THE HOMELESS CRISIS THAT WE
HAVE IN IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS THAT WE HAVE -- BUT I
THINK THIS IS A A TOOL THAT I
LIKE TO SEE HOW IT WORKS IN
THESE IN THESE COUNTIES IN.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT IT'S THAT
IS SUCCESSFUL -- LOOK AT HOW WE
CAN EXPAND THAT OUT.
SO CHANGE SHOULD THE AUTHOR AND
I WILL BE SUPPORT IN THE BILL
TODAY.
THANK YOU IT'S A TWO I'M A VERY
BRIEF FIVE BECAUSE I THINK MANY
OF THE SENTIMENTS THAT I SHARE
OF ALREADY BEEN -- HAVE ALREADY
BEEN DELINEATED BUT I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR -- FOR FOR
MOVING THIS FOR I THINK YOU AND
THIS BILL ARE OFTEN
MISINTERPRETED AND MISUNDERSTOOD --
BUT THE REALITY IS AND TOO MANY
OF OUR STREETS AND CERTAINLY AND
THE CITY THAT YOU AND I SHARE
REPRESENTING -- WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
LITERALLY IN TREMENDOUS
RESTAURANT IS HARMON ARE DYING
ON OUR STREETS AND WE HAVE TO DO
MORE WE HAVE TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY.
AND I HAPPEN TO BE ONE WHO
THINKS IT IS PROGRESSIVE FOR US
AS A STATE. TO PROVIDE THE HELP
THAT THEY NEED TO DO IT IN A
VERY CAREFULLY SCULPTED WAY
WHICH I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS --
AND TO DO WITHIN THE FRAMEWORK
OF ALL THE OTHER THINGS THAT WE
DO IN THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT WE SPEND -- TO TO ADDRESS
THIS NEED SO -- CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE PERSPECTIVE OF
THE OPPOSITION AND I KNOW THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS IT'S NOT HARD AND
HOW TO INCORPORATE -- THE VALID
FEEDBACK -- BUT WITH THAT --
LOOK FOR TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THAT
CONCERNS ME IS WHEN WE START
TALKING ABOUT DETAINING PEOPLE
FOR THEIR OWN GOOD BECAUSE OFTEN
THE CONVERSATION ENDS THERE.
AND IF THAT'S ALL WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT IT BECOMES TO
TENSIONS ROOF KIND OF THE
CONVENIENCE OF OF OTHERS RATHER
THAN SOMETHING THAT THAT.
REALLY IS TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEMS THAT THAT
ARE THERE.
AND THAT'S WHY FOR THIS
COMMITTEE.
I REALLY PUSHED BACK IN AND THE
HAD STAFF PUSHED BACK TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE PUTTING SOME
APPROPRIATE BOUNDS AROUND THIS
INCLUDING THE DATA COLLECTION.
BECAUSE SENSE.
YOUR LAST BILL PASSED ACTUALLY
BEEN APPROACHED BY A NUMBER OF
COUNTIES WHO WANT TO PARTAKE IN
THIS AND I FOR ONE AM UNWILLING
TO DO THAT AND I THINK WE SHOULD
BE VERY CAUTIOUS.
IN EXPANDING THIS PILOT UNTIL WE
GET SOME REAL DATA IN ABOUT.
WHO'S BEING SERVED HOW THEY'RE
BEING SERVED WHAT HAPPENS TO
THESE INDIVIDUALS.
AND COUNTIES WITHOUT THE SAME
RESOURCES OR WITHOUT THE SAME
COMMITMENT. TO REALLY RESOLVING
SOME OF THE ISSUES COULD USE
THESE TOOLS IN A WAY THAT I
THINK A LOT OF US MIGHT FIND AN
APPROPRIATE.
AND REALLY MORE TOWARDS THE
DETENTION FOR THE SAKE OF
DETENTION.
AS OPPOSED TO A STRUCTURE THAT
THAT.
REALLY ADDRESSES THE MOST
DIFFICULT INDIVIDUALS TO SERVE.
AND SERVICE THEM.
IN AN APPROPRIATE WAY.
SO THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF THE
BALANCE WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
STRIKE AND AND MAKE SURE THAT.
WE ARE REALLY ADDRESSING THE
UNDERLYING NEEDS AND IF WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE PROCESS WE
BEING STATE CALIFORNIA AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF DETAINING
SOMEONE.
THEN WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES. FIFTY ONE FIFTIES
PRETTY LOW STANDARD YES EIGHT OF
THEM ARE A LOT.
BUT FIFTY ONE FIFTIES OFTEN GET
USED AGAIN AND AGAIN WHAT WE
WOULD HATE TO SEE A CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE SOMEBODY HAS SEVERAL FIFTY
ONE FIFTIES AND THEN IT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AS WELL IF WE JUST
DO A COUPLE MORE.
WE CAN THEN DETAIN THAT WE CAN
DO OTHER THINGS FOR THEM.
THAT'S NOT THE REASON FOR THE
FIFTY ONE FIFTIES IN FACT
THERE'S A FIFTY TO FIFTY SECTION
WHICH REQUIRES A LOT MORE.
OF A MENTAL HEALTH ANALYSIS OF
AN INDIVIDUAL THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
TRYING TO PUSH THIS MORE TOWARDS
THAT SO THAT.
THERE ARE [inaudible]
OFTEN.
IT MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE ABUSE
OFTEN GO HAND IN HAND BUT NOT
ALWAYS SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE ARE APPLYING THE RATE.
REMEDIES TO THE SITUATION AGAIN
RATHER THAN JUST SWEEPING PEOPLE
UP FOR THE CONVENIENCE OF OF THE
LOCAL JURISDICTION.
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
CALIFORNIA'S NOT REALLY
FUNCTIONING THAT WELL WE KNOW
THAT IT'S BEEN BROKEN FOR A LONG
TIME LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
BEEN STRUGGLING WITH THAT.
THE FACT THAT.
COUNTIES AND EVEN THE STATOR
SITTING ON SO MUCH MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT MONEY WITHOUT BEING
ABLE TO SPEND IT.
THAT SHOULD THAT SHOULD BE AN
ALARM BELL TO US THAT THAT IT'S
NOT WORKING BECAUSE THERE IS
MONEY TO BE ABLE TO BE APPLIED
IT JUST.
ISN'T AND I THINK THAT.
THE STATE HAS A LOT OF
RESPONSIBILITY THERE BECAUSE IT
HAS NOT BEEN SUPPORTING COUNTIES
IN GETTING THAT'S MONEY SPENT OR
BEEN WILLING TO GET MONEY SPENT
WHICH WOULD REALLY HELP.
DEALING WITH SOME OF THESE EXACT
POPULATIONS.
BUT IT'S BEEN FRACTURED FOR A
LONG TIME ESPECIALLY GO BACK TO
THE TIME WHEN WE CLOSED.
STATE CLOSED -- MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITIES WITHOUT ANY.
REPLACEMENT WITHOUT ANY FOLLOW
UP OR ABILITY TO PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITIES AND
WE SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT.
BUT A HEALTH BETS JUVENILE ADULT
MEN HEALTH AS WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT HOW WE PUT THOSE
RESOURCES BACK IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE MOST.
CHRONIC.
CASES THAT THAT WE SEE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES SO THAT'S A LITTLE
BIT OF OF THE SENSITIVITY AND
CENTER UNIT.
THAT CONVERSATION.
SO AS THIS MOVES FORWARD.
THEY WITH THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
NEED TO TAKE THE RESPONSIBILITY
TO SAY OKAY WE'VE ALLOWED THIS
TO MOVE FORWARD WE HAVE TO BE
HOLDING.
SERVICES GO AND THE TEEN DIEGO
LA SHOULD THEY CHOOSE TO ADOPT
THIS ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT
HAPPENS FOR THE NUMBERS.
BECAUSE AS A PILOT AS MISTER
KALRA SAYS.
IT'S GONNA BE VERY TEMPTING FOR
OTHER JURISDICTIONS THEY'LL LET
US JUMP IN LATEST BUT ISSUES
THIS AS WELL.
AND WHAT WE NEED TO LEARN FROM
THIS PILOT FROM THE DATA
COLLECTION IS WHAT WORKED WHAT
DIDN'T WORK.
SO THAT WE CAN FOR NARROW ITS
ITS USE OVER TIME IN A WAY
THAT'S MOST APPROPRIATE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND ANY JURISDICTION
THAT WANTS TO STEP IN.
IS GOING TO HAVE TO PUT SOME
RESOURCES ON THE TABLE WHICH I
KNOW SAM CISCO WELL.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE YOU HAVE.
PUT A LOT OF RESOURCES IN TO TRY
AND MANAGE POPULATIONS THAT'S
REALLY THE BALLOTS WERE TRYING
TO FIGHT HERE SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR WILLINGNESS.
TO TALK THROUGH THIS I KNOW
YOU'RE YOU'RE SENSITIVE TO THESE
SAME ISSUES AND WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE.
SUCCESSFUL IN TERMS OF SCOPE NOT
JUST FOR THE CITY BUT FOR THE
PEOPLE INVOLVED AND THAT'S THANK
YOU SENATOR AND WITH THAT YOU
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU CARDS FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS -- HIGH --
IN TERMS OF FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
RACIST COMMENTS IT IS AWKWARD
BECAUSE I AUTHOR SPONSORED BILLS
FOR THE WESTERN CENTER AND THE
ACLU MULTIPLE ONES EVERY YEAR
THESE OUR ALLIES PEOPLE ON THE
LINE WITH.
ON ON EVERYTHING BUT YOU KNOW
ONCE IN AWHILE YOU HAVE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES AND THE
OPPONENTS THIS BILL I I DON'T
CRITICIZE THEM AT ALL THEY ARE.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE.
PLAYING A VERY CRITICAL ROLE AND
SO I RESPECT WHERE THERE ARE
COMING FROM THAT I'M GLAD THAT
WE WILL LEAST BEEN ABLE TO CLOSE
THE GAP TO SOMEWHAT.
ON AND I AGREE THAT HOUSING
FIRST IS HELPING IS KEY TO
EVERYTHING BUT SOMETIMES PEOPLE --
NEED TO TRANSITION AND THE
HOUSING AND NEED SOME HELP TO
GET STABLE ENOUGH SO THAT THEIR
SUCCESSFUL -- IN THAT -- IN THAT
HOUSING AND IS TO BE VERY CLEAR --
AS SOMEONE SAID TO ME RECENTLY
WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
A CONSERVATORSHIP SYSTEM BUT AT
THE CAN A SYSTEM THAT IS A
COMBINATION OF CYCLING PEOPLE TO
FIFTY ONE FIFTIES WHERE THEY DO
NOT GET THE EVALUATIONS THAT
THEY NEED.
CYCLING PEOPLE TO JAIL.
AND THEN IN BETWEEN THEY'RE OUT
ON THE STREETS.
RATING THAT'S THE SORT OF
CONSERVATORSHIP QUOTE ON QUOTE
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE AND THE LAST
THING WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE
CONSTANTLY HAVING CONTACT WITH
THE POLICE -- AND CONSTANTLY
CYCLING THROUGH JAIL AND MORE
MORE FOR THE ONE FIFTIES LET'S
GET THESE FOLKS STABLE AND
HEALTHY AND ON WITH THEIR LIVES
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IDOL.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION TO
SECOND THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
HEALTH COMMITTEE CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CHOW CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS IRATE S..
REYES AYE THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU ALRIGHT
LET'S GO BACK THROUGH THE AGENDA
AND CATCH WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
ITEMS THAT ARE ON CALL SOME THAT
ARE NOT ON CALL.
SO WE'LL START WITH CAN SENSE
WHICH IS.
OUT BUT CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CHOW.
CHOW I TO CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I PETRIE-NORRIS
BETWEEN NORTH SIDE THANK YOU I
REMEMBER WHEN WE TOOK CARE OF
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB ONE SEVEN ONE
JACKSON IS ON CALL I'M GONNA
LIFT THE CALL.
CHAO CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
NO.
THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB TWO TWENTY TWO HILL IS
ON CALL OF AND LIFT THE CALL
CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I
THE BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SB THREE EIGHTEEN HERTZBERG IS
ON CALL A MIDDLE OF THE CALL --
CALL HAVE SOME MEMBERS PLEASE
[inaudible]
CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I THE BILL IS OUT
ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS ALSO CALL SB
THREE TWENTY SIX HELL I'M GONNA
LIVE THE CALL CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHU CHU AYE HOLDEN.
I OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I THAT BILL IS OUT.
THE LAST ITEM ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
SB THREE SEVENTY SEVEN MCGUIRE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS CHOW.
CHOW I CHU CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I
PETRIE-NORRIS.
NORTH SIDE.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNMENTS